pieces out.
I don't hear anyone.
Sorry, they have the room on mute so we
can't hear the actual room. Okay.
Luckily, you can hear me, right? Yeah,
we can hear you now. I can hear you. Hi,
Sandy.
Okay. Um, and you know, you people on
Zoom know that you have to have your
cameras on. So, my cameras on.
Excellent. Excellent. Um, yeah. No one
may speak until granted the floor.
Please raise your hand and wait for me
to recognize you. It is important that
only one person speaks at a time so that
members of the public watching at home
can understand what is being said.
Members of the public, if you wish to
give remarks during the public session
and have not already already registered
by signing um by filling out a form, you
can register to speak on Zoom by using
the Q&A feature and posting your name,
affiliation, and the specific topic you
wish to speak about. If you're here in
person to speak in the public session,
you need to fill out our public speaker
form, which is ordered by Brian. Um, and
this needs to be done by 7:15.
If you've already signed up online
though, you don't have to do that. Okay.
Um, the agenda for tonight's meeting was
distributed ahead of time by the board
office, was posted online, and appears
on the screen before you. If there is no
objection, we will adopt the agenda as
stated. Board members, if you object to
adopting the agenda, you may raise your
hand. Seeing no objections, the agenda
for tonight's meeting is adopted. Our
secretary, Justin Goldberg, will now
take the attendance by roll
call. One minute.
You will now take call members. When
your name is called, please say present.
Tanya Aras, present. Kyle Ty, present.
Neil Barlay present.
Martin Barrett
present.
LB Barroso present.
Daniel Bernstein present.
Liz B
present.
Jim Collins.
Steuart Desert present.
Beatrice Stman,
Maya
Donghue, Robert Bear,
Bar Freeman, present. Jason Britz,
Eric Goldberg,
Goldberg, President Gloria H.
Yeah.
God. Absent. John Keller present. Nate
Kennedy.
Nadine Palani.
Katie Landa. Present. Sandra Lov
present.
David Levy.
Anton present. Sand Key present. Alec
Militic present.
Richard
miss Keith present hotel present
Stephen Carz present
will
Harry Omar Kishi
he's absent Marian
Roth Michael and row
Lauren Sh present and
absent. Sandra Sherrod present.
Sadiki present.
Laddyy Simon present.
Mark Thompson
present.
Gabriel Tzo
presero, James
Zer, Jerry Winstein present.
Sarah Whittington,
David Wood,
Shua Zowl.
With 36
of 50 members present, we do have
quorum. Our elected officials sent in
their reports ahead of time and they are
compiled on the CB6 website. The link to
the reports was sent out ahead of time
and for your convenience can be found in
the chat on Zoom or by going through our
websit's page for full board meetings. I
will now call in each of the elected
officials who have RSVPd so that they
can take questions from CB6 members and
the public from their presubmitted
reports. Each elected official will be
able to field questions. If there are no
questions, we will move to the next
elected official on our list. If an
elected official has a time-sensitive
matter to report on that they didn't
make into their presubmitted support,
they will have three minutes to do so.
During this part of the meeting, we'll
also hear, excuse me, from government
agency representatives who have
requested to address the board tonight.
First on our list, we have Alex Garcia
from District Attorney Brad's office.
Alex. Uh, he has his hand raised.
You, Alex, you should be able to speak
now. Why is my camera not on? Um, I'm
having some camera issues. I'm not sure
why. I can promote you to a panelist and
you should be able to have your camera
on. Okay. Yeah, I kind of need to.
Um, thank you so much for that. Sorry, I
don't hope to delay anything or anyone.
Um, I do have um some announcements to
make. So, I'm going on behalf of the
Manhattan days office. I'll get through
those as quickly as possible. So um it
our offices announced the indictment of
an individual
uh for making terrorist threats against
a central synagogue and the Jewish
community on February 13th through 14th,
2025. The individual reportedly posted
threats on excluding a pan a plan to
attack Shabbat services and identifying
as the reincarnation of Hitler
threatening further violence against
Jewish people. He was arrested and route
to Manhattan. our office. Um to quote
director um district attorney Brag
directly, nobody should have to fear
their safety when they are in a house of
worship and the language really
allegedly used by the defendant is
extremely
disturbing. My office will remain
vigilant against any and all threats to
the Jewish community and I hope our
prosecutors and law enforcement partners
for this work on this matter. Um, next,
our office would like to announce the
indictment of an individual for
allegedly sexually assaulting six women
in his Midtown apartment between 2024
and March
2025. The 116count indictment includes
charges of predatory sexual assault,
rape, facilitating a sex offense with a
controlled substance, assault, bribing a
witness, and weapons related charges.
The individual uh allegedly raped and
violently assaulted the women,
threatening them, and used his position
as an attorney to intimidate them. to
quote uh Alvin Bragg, "This
investigation is ongoing. We have a
reason to believe there may be
additional survivors. Our talented
prosecutors and investigators as well as
our specially trained counselors are
here to support you, no matter how
powerful the person who assaulted you
seem to be. Please call special victim
submission hotlines and I will also put
it in the chat. It is 212
3353400. Thank you." And lastly, um, our
office would actually announce the
sentencing of Midtown postal workers
Destiny Anderson and her partner Anthony
Johnson for the credit cards and checks
from the mail. Anderson received three
years of conditional discharge while
Johnson faced one and a half to three
years in prison. Um, they both worked at
the postal office at Rockefeller
building. That is it. Thank you.
Okay. Um, good news and bad news.
seconds. Do we have do we have any
questions for
Alex? Seeing none, thank you very much.
We'll move on to Braa
Rosenberg. Braa, are you
Yes. Sorry, can you come back to I'm
having a technical difficulties on my
end, but I should resolve them in the
next few minutes. Absolutely. Um Joanna
Sanchez from Assembly Member Epstein's
office.
You got you got someone different. Oh,
okay. Harvey Epstein from Harvey
Epstein.
Epste is I don't want to take Joanna's
thunder, but I'm happy to talk. You're
welcome.
I just wanted to hope everyone's doing
well. Happy uh
miday. Uh just wanted to give folks, you
know, we had a really late budget this
year. We just passed it last Thursday.
Just wanted to give a quick update. It's
in our report, but so there's a lot of
things in there for the $254 billion
budget. A lot of great stuff on housing
we put in about supporting existing
middle- inome housing. Uh Mitchell
Llamas, reducing the tax rate for
Mitchell Lamas. A lot of money that we
did for environmental issues. The bell
to bail ban on cell phones in schools as
a controversial issue uh that we were
able to pass to make sure all public
schools now are not going to have kids
have phones during the school
day. There's a bunch of things on on
discovery changes as well as a mask
issue. I don't know if the governor
really pushed for a mask change and we
did a minor mass change to to make mass
potentially a crime in addition to some
other violation. But overall the budget
was a healthy budget and really lived up
to our values on the housing
environment, you know, education. We put
a lot of money into our schools, public
safety, more supportive housing units,
really switching away our existing 911
system to try to create a new system,
the mental health response, the higher
education, the things that we we've been
talking about here in the board and
things that I've been fighting for. So,
I think we should all be proud. And for
folks who are uh you know making under
300,000 as a couple or 150,000 as a
individual, you'll be getting checks
later this year from the state. And I'm
happy to talk about more about the
budget, but I know you have a lot of
people. Um, you know, the last thing
I'll say is we have a a couple couple
upcoming events. We're doing what we
call hang with Harvey in June and we'll
have our last shredding for the spring
on June 6. If you want compare shredding
event is in our eblast and our
newsletter and you don't get our eblast,
you just sign up for them to get all the
information about we're doing in the
neighborhood.
Thank you, Har. Do we have any
questions?
First, thank you. Uh, Daniel's law. Um,
I'll ask you if you could just briefly
describe it. Uh, and then the question
is what we can do. It's the intersection
essentially of public safety and mental
health. Uh, and uh, the question is what
we might be able to do to help um,
implement it in our district. It's my
understanding that one reason that we
often send dispatch police uh to 911
calls with when there's an emotional
emotionally distressed person rather
than mental health specialists is
because we just don't have the teams in
our community district um especially
rebell speaking so I can't really see
who's asking the question but it's a
really good question Um,
it's Stu. Okay, great. St. So, for
people who don't know what Daniel's Law
is, basically in the city in the city of
Rochester, a guy named Daniel
Puit and then so Daniel um who had a who
had real mental health issues
unfortunately um when the 911 called the
police responded and unfortunately
Daniel passed away from uh his
interaction with the police. And what
Rochester realized and what we all
realize is that sometimes the response
doesn't need to be a police response,
it's a mental health response. And so
that's what how Daniel's law was
created. And the city of Rochester, like
Southern California now, has a real
comprehensive approach to the 911
system. The answer isn't just the
police. The answer is who's the best
professional to respond to that. So, we
put another $8 million in uh to create a
behavioral health crisis uh technical
assistance center, which will help first
responders understand how to respond to
the mental health crisis. So, it's
really upgrading our 911 system, really
revamping it to make sure that we have
the mental health professional to
respond to mental health issu episodes.
So, I think it's one is a training for
our 911 system, which I think hopefully
in this budget we're starting to move in
that direction, and two is figuring out
how we can fully implement Daniel's law
across the state. You know, again, we
put, you know, money in for supportive
housing beds. You know, we we need more
mental health beds. We put 200, you
know, basically another $30 million for
supportive housing beds, another $20
million into impatient mental health
beds, and we changed the category on
voluntaries. All those things together
with a real 911 system will help us, I
think, get in the right direction. I
don't think there's a one-sizefititall
thing. But I do know that unless we have
the support of housing beds at the end,
we're never going to get to the place we
need to be because you can you can
involuntarily commit someone, but sooner
or later they're coming out. And the
other piece is making sure that on the
front end like you said to that that we
have a real response that's driven by
mental health professionals for mental
health issues. Our police are not
trained in that way. You know, like I'm
trained as a lawyer, but never give me
an intellectual property case. I would
screw it up. Police are not trained to
be mental health professionals, and we
just know that. And we have better
systems and structures in place.
Exactly, buddy. Um, sorry, it's a long
question, but it's a long answer, but
it's a really complicated question. I
think we're going in the right
direction. Don't worry.
um the budget um allocates 15 million
just to support changes in discovery.
Uh wasn't substantially changed uh
despite the government threats. Um do
you know what that 15 million is going
toward? Yeah, I could tell you exactly
what it's going to. So 5 million for the
for the DAs in New York City, five
million for the DAs outside of New York
City, five million for the defense
lawyers. And so basically they each get
$5 million. And basically what we did
with discovery is uh what we heard in
New York City was especially from our DA
Manhattan DA bra we just had a
representative on the phone a few
minutes ago was there were cases let's
say an example that there was a domestic
violence case
[Music]
and the person who was you know was
assaulted handed over their phone. So
they handed over all the evidence, but
they found out that a friend of the
survivor had a a picture of the survivor
on her phone and they just didn't know
about the picture, so they didn't hand
it over. And they said a case like that
was dismissed where the DA attempted to
provide all outstanding information but
missed something because they didn't
know it existed. So what we've done is
uh there's a court case called Peoplebe.
people vay and in that case it outlined
um basically the real specific standards
of why cases should be dismissed or not.
What we did is we took the standards
that people be and put them into the
statute. So to make sure that it was
clear to all the judges whe they they
where where how much were the
obligations of the DAs to hand over and
if they handed that over whether they
complied enough to ensure that the case
should go forward and that some
technical mistakes like something like
this where you handed you didn't hand
over a footer you didn't know existed
that should result in a dismissal of a
case but if you don't comply with
discovery hand over police records in
that case the people be case was they
failed to hand over 911 records they
said didn't exist but it actually did
exist and in that case the case was
dismissed. So the judge wants to look
holistically at the standard and that's
how we we changed the discovery to make
clear that the other change we did was
if the defense wanted to object to what
uh the DA handed over they had 35 days
um there's a requirement under the law
that when they they're ready for trial
under the speedy trial rules they have
to submit a notice saying hey we're
ready for trial within 35 days of that
notice that if the if the defense team
thinks there's something that hasn't
been complied with they have 35 days to
compel it or ask the judge to dismiss
the case. Under the current law was much
more open-ended. So, we wanted to give
everyone a clear time frame, which is
really what we're trying to do is make
sure all the parties have good
information and clear time frames.
Basic question though is what what are
those $5 million um grants to to defend
the prosecutor going to accomplish? Are
they for technology or No, this is this
is for staff. So, what we heard from the
DA's office and the defense lawyers
They just needed more staff to help
comply with the obligations under
discovery, more parallegals, more
support staff. So, both the defense
lawyers and the prosecutors got
additional funds. Okay. Thanks. Um
lastly, um you come to speak with us a
uh frequently and we really appreciate
that. Um and you often uh take questions
from us. Uh and um you have to my
recollection never asked us for
anything. Um what can we do? Um assuming
we agree with you
or some of your action. Yeah. You know,
it's funny because I do ask Sandy for
stuff like I'm like give me a resolution
in support of the issue we're working
on. I've done that many times. Um and so
I will continue to ask for things. I
probably won't do it publicly in a
meeting, but if I there's an issue we're
trying to get done legislatively, you
know, we're trying to, you know, one
example is, you know, we've, you know,
we're talking about moving to the
climate goals, but we have no publicly
available charging infrastructure in
lower Manhattan. We have no charging
stations publicly available below 59th
Street. So, things like asking the city
to put publicly available charging
infrastructure in a in a part of the
city which is in the congestion zone,
then we want people to move to electric
vehicles. Um, we talked about more money
for, you know, in the budget, we got
more money for composting. Making sure
that we have more access to composting
in our community, not just the
composting that we're talking about on
the street corner and the pickups, but
also uh composting that goes to dirt
like we have with the lower east side.
There's all those things that you know,
which I when you guys are doing it, I
really appreciate it. I asked about the
casino. Really wanted to hear back from
the board about where you were on the
casino and the board, you know, gave me
a clear
information about the casino that
there's being proposed between on 1st
Avenue between 38th and 42nd. So I I
feel like we have a really good open
dialogue and I do appreciate the board's
response to this to my request. I also
meet sit down with the when you guys do
your capital needs and operating needs,
I sit down with the chair and we talk
through what your needs are and to make
sure that if we're funding things,
funding things that you've identified as
needs in our community. Uh, so I I guess
I I feel like I asked, but I'm happy to
ask more.
Thank you. Thank you. Yes. We we do what
we can.
Great. Uh, so no more questions. Thank
you all. Have a great evening and we'll
be, you know, we're still up here in
Albany, but we'll have about another
month of legislative session. So, if
there are bills you want us to move
forward on, I have about a dozen bills
I'm trying to get done in the board.
Please let me know. We have we have
about, you know, about 25 legislative
days left in the session.
Great. Okay, the final push. Thanks very
much. Thank you.
Uh, we'll go back to Braa.
Hi. Sorry about that. My um my computer
decided to update, so I was on my phone
and I I want to get my notes back up. Um
hi everyone. The most exciting thing
which you'll see in the um the report is
uh that we have released our newest
appointments uh for community board
members. So welcome to all the new
members. Everyone please say hi um to
the new members. I already feel like I
know you from from your applications and
everything because they were they were
so good. Um but I'm excited to get to
know you more and you can always reach
out to me as well. Um we had over 950
applications across the burrow uh that
our team's been working really hard on
um reviewing and um making the final
appointments and some of the boards are
still finishing up those. Um but we're
very excited for uh these new members
now. Um and then the rest you can really
read in the report, but um I just I've
been getting a lot of specific questions
about term limits from people on this
board. Um so you can always ask me but
also information about maximum term
limits is available on our website. Uh I
put instructions in the report on how
you can find that. Um but that should
answer your questions there. Um and we
had a really wonderful AAPI event um
together with Assembly Member Grace Lee
um this week, sorry, last week. Uh and
um feel free to look on our social media
for some more about that. Um and finally
the stops super speeders bill uh that
the bar president participated at a
rally to uh urge Albany to pass it. Uh
because the statistics around reckless
driving and and um accidents and
pedestrian deaths are are really really
alarming. Um so we are um encouraging
this leg legislation that would mandate
speed limiter technology for the most
dangerous drivers on our street. Uh
that's all I have and happy to take any
questions. Um Tanya has a question.
Hi Bara, I'm glad you touched on this
super speeders. Um, it's not only super
speeders, it's people who don't respect
um the pedestrians on crosswalks. I
personally have been run down on a
crosswalk even though I hadn't ride
away. So the pedestrians death and and
injury go above and beyond just speed.
Is there anything else that you're
doing? for example, like the timing of
the lights um at intersections and such.
That might help. Thanks. Um I don't know
specifically about in terms of
infrastructure, timing the lights.
That's something we can definitely look
into and perhaps our transportation team
is already on it. I can definitely speak
to them about it. Um I do know that
we've done other things around uh
traffic safety. Um we've worked
extensively on ghost cars. Um you know,
cars that um drive recklessly and and
use fake license plates that they can't
get tickets. Uh and we have a lot of we
have a whole um package of
recommendations that we've come out with
around that. Um because that um is not
only costing the city revenue, but it's
also cost costing people's lives. Um and
um killing two birds with Flintstone
would be wonderful if we could cut down
on that. Uh and we're always looking for
more ideas on how to make our streets uh
safer um for for pedestrians um and and
everyone on the roads. Um, so yeah,
please feel free to share ideas like
that and then I can definitely flag to
our uh transportation analyst and our
policy team as well um to find out any
any more things that we're working on.
Thank you. Great. Great. Thank you,
Brock. Seeing no more questions, we'll
move on to Justin Flag from Senator
Krueger's office.
Good evening. Um, nothing extra to
report. Just want to point out that um
we have we uploaded two reports this
month. One is our regular monthly um
newsletter that came out a couple weeks
ago and then one was our budget update
from earlier this week that has um a lot
of detail about what's in the budget. So
you can take a look at both of those um
on the website and happy to take any
questions.
Due has a question for you.
evening. Um I wanted to ask you about
the substantial equivalency standards.
Uh I'll ask you to just briefly explain
what that is and then um I'll say that
in our district we don't exactly have a
plethora of um yeshivas. Does it somehow
still impact the schools uh
within district six?
So um just quickly substantial
equivalency are the standards that um
non-public schools have to meet um to
meet the state constitutional
requirement for providing a sound basic
education. Um and this has been uh an
issue uh often um in relation to uh
yeshivas and and whether or not they're
provide they're meeting that standard.
Um, and so this was an issue in the
budget. Um, I'll just say quickly that
before I get to your specific question,
Stu, um, Senator Krueger was very
opposed to the changes to substantial
equivalency that were made in the
budget.
Um, if you look at our our budget
update, um, there's a link there for uh,
a video of her speaking on the floor
specifically about that issue. And I
think she puts it very clearly, so I
won't try to repeat what she said there,
but you can find it there.
Um, in terms of this district, um, I
mean, it applies to all non-public
schools. So, if there's any, you know,
private schools, even if you know,
whether they're religious or not, um,
they all, uh, have to abide by those
substantial equivalency standards. So
when we change the uh method by which
those standards are met then it it does
apply to those schools as well.
Good. Do we have any other
questions? Okay. Thank you um Justin. Um
we'll move on to Payton Schaefus from
Senator Gonzalez's office.
Hi dad, but have you taken questions?
Do we have any questions for Peyton?
Report was right. I guess we we might
have one question just I know um now
that MSBI is closed. We're wondering
what the next steps are. I think
everyone knows we're very concerned
about the lack of of hospital care in
our district, especially the lower
portion of the district. Mhm. So, is
there something that the senator is
working on in in Albany to help us with
that? Yes, absolutely. One of our
priorities obviously has been making
sure that Belleview uh has adequate
funding is able to um have the increased
capacity that it's going to need for the
additional patients that will be going
there. We're also continuing to fight
for legislation like the um Lich and
statewide healthcare assessment measures
that will uh
help you know change the ways by which
um some of these decisions are decisions
are made. Um that won't necessarily undo
the damage that's done by the closure
not made by this trail.
Part of the goal with the statewide
healthcare assessment legislation would
be to identify um healthcare distressed
zones, areas that are in need of more
investment. So that way more investment
could be directed there. And we do have
a resolution in support of Lich. So
hopefully it comes up again this this
year, I guess. Great. Thank you. Any
other questions?
No. Thanks very much. We'll move on to
um Mackie Dentley from Congressman
Adler's office.
Hi there everyone. Uh the board happy to
take any questions.
Okay.
Report has a question.
There was some something in the report
about local's $50 million rental aid
program. Can you explain what that is?
Yeah. So, I don't have the details in
front of me, but uh Army Nyler did write
a letter in support of funding for um is
it
HBCAP? Um I forget the acronym. Um but
in support of adequate funding for that
in you know light of all these potential
cuts with budget um and you
know there's a new state um program that
will assist with rental assistance um
from what I've seen. I don't know the
exact details about it. I know some of
my colleagues would have more details on
that but that was announced I think two
weeks ago. Um, but I'm happy to get more
information and, you know, follow up
with on that if you like. Okay, great.
Go ahead. I think it's like a section
eight, a statewide section 8 like
health, isn't it? Uh, again, it's been a
minute, so I'm not entirely sure. That's
what I read,
but I'm happy to follow up on that.
Okay, thanks very much. Um, we'll move
on to Shinray Lee from the Independent
Budget Office. He's here. Oh, great.
Thank you. Hi, good evening everyone.
Uh, my name is Simray. I'm the community
engagement specialist from the New York
City Independent Budget Office. Um, so
could I just get a show of hands who is
familiar with our agency?
Oh, good number of people, not not you
know, still some strugglers. So, uh, I'm
here to introduce us. Um, we've been
around, we are a city agency. Um, but we
are independent in the sense that we
don't report to any elected officials.
Um our primary function is to provide
datadriven information on recommend
services, programs, etc. the budget uh
to the public and city council members.
Uh we do this through three charter
mandate reports that come out in
conjunction with the mayor's budget
plans. So we are currently analyzing the
executive budget that just came out
earlier this month. Um our analysis will
be coming out in a couple of weeks or
actually next week. Um, so stay tuned
for that. Um, otherwise we also do
presentations. Uh, I'm a relatively new
member of the team, so we're kind of
doing more outreach. Um, we're doing
presentations at schools. So if you have
a high school that wants to learn more
about the budget, uh, we can come
through. Um, we'll also be doing a
budget 101 workshop uh, geared towards
community board members. Uh, I have some
flyers over here that you can grab uh,
or scan the QR code over there um, to
register. There are three sessions to
choose from. Uh it's on May 28th and
29th. Um we'll be going through the
structure, the process, timeline of the
New York City budget. Um so if you don't
know what you know PS or OTPS means, you
should come. Or if you don't know what
an expense budget versus the capital
budget is or how that works, uh we'll go
through that. Um and we'll also cover a
little bit about how the community board
needs assessment fits into the budget
process.
Um yeah, apart from the charter mandated
reports, we also publish reports year
round about uh we have 50 analysts who
are experts in things from housing,
environment, infrastructure, education.
Uh we released a report recently on the
age of school buildings for example and
how accessible they are. Um and there's
a lot more reports. We testified
recently uh on the street vendors permit
cap. Um so go to our website
ibo.nyc.gov and you can see what we
have. Um and we accept questions from
the public on the budget uh and any
other budget related data
questions. Uh we also provide like
reports from council members and the
public. So send us an email over there.
Grab a flyer. Sign up for the budget
101. That's it. Thank you. Thank you. I
highly recommend all of our new members
sign up. I'm going to sign up, too. Y
make a day of it. Yes. It's it's really
important information. I'm
really Okay. Um next we have Evelyn
Colado from Controller Lander's office.
Yes. Uh good evening. Um Manhattan B
director for uh New York City Control
Brett Lander. Thank you for the
opportunity to address you tonight. Um,
tonight I'd like to bring your attention
to two of our latest reports. The first
one is a contract primer. Uh, we
released it as part of our efforts to
provide the public with a
straightforward to the basics of city
contracting workflows and essential
solistation methods. Uh the document is
divided into three overarching sections
including the primer with uh information
on key entities in New York City
contracting, an overview of the New York
City contracting cycle, definitions of
core contract categories and
solicitation methods and more. It also
has a section on public resources. And
the last se section is uh uh a set of
helpful tables for navigating the primer
and running searches in the systems
outlined in section two. The other
report that I'd like to bring to your
attention is the streets for people open
streets and the future of public space
management in New York City. Uh in this
report we evaluated how the open streets
program is has evolved over the last
five years. Uh tracing the shift in the
size, scale and geographic locations of
open streets over time and documenting
the various challenges that operators
face in effectively managing and uh and
programming open streets. It is informed
by an analysis of publicly available
data along with over 30 interviews with
open street operators. uh public realm
experts and a review of global best
practices for public space
pedestrianization. The report proposes
strategic recommendations to strengthen
the program into a thriving fixture of
New York City's urban landscape. For
this uh and other audits and reports,
you can visit us at
controller.nyc.gov. Thank you and good
evening.
Do we have any questions?
Okay, great. Thank you very much. We'll
move on then to Sophie Sakor from um
um Assembly Member Bores's office.
Sophie, are you there?
Sorry about that. Yes, here. Um, nothing
to add from the report other than we
have um free legal services that will be
at our office this Friday from 10 a.m.
until 2 p.m. Um, and that wasn't in the
report, but I can take any questions
from the report now if you have any.
Do we have any questions
for Okay, seeing none, we'll move on um
to Spencer Spencer from Council
Member Rivera's office. He's going to be
accompanied by Katie Lo.
Hi everyone. Katie Lo from Council
Member River's office. Um I've been the
CD6 rep for I don't know seven years now
and it's time to pass the torch. So I
want to introduce everyone to Spencer
He's been working in our office
part-time for two years for for almost
two years. So he's very well seasoned.
He's very familiar with a lot of issues
in the area. He's been working very
closely on East 28th Street. Um, so he's
going to be the new CD6 rep. So I wanted
to introduce him and say bye to
everybody. I'll miss you on the second
Wednesday of every month. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Very good.
Hi
everyone. Very nice to meet you all. Uh,
as Katie mentioned, I've been working
for Council Member Rivera for a couple
years now, part time, helping out with
budget and outreach most recently, but
checking into
CB6. Um, pretty familiar with the issues
around here. I grew up in village as
well, not quite in CB6, but close enough
to find that. So, I'm I'm excited to get
to know everyone better and uh, yeah,
look forward to working.
Thank you. Thank welcome. Thank you.
Right. Do we have any questions?
just, you know, start off on
a Okay, it's a good thing. It's a good
thing. Thank you. Thank you very much.
Um, all right. We're going to move on to
the public session. Has anyone signed up
to speak in the public session? They
have. Um, quite a few. Um, all right.
You will be granted uh three minutes to
speak. Uh, we will start with Sha
Lamuru.
Sean, are you here? Uh Shawn is a
resident of Manhattan Community District
6 and wishes to speak to the board on
increasing green infrastructure in
Manhattan Community District 6. Mr.
Lamaru, you have three minutes. You may
begin your remarks now. All right. Um I
I live in your city and um I did present
a deck, but I guess it's not there.
Basically, um I would like to see
increase uh green infrastructure in our
community. Um as many know this reduces
heat island effect, absorbs flood
waters, enhance local biodiversity, it
improves our mental and physical health.
Um the more we dedicate public space to
people and natural landscapes instead of
asphalt and concrete for personal cars,
our local grows, our property values
increase, and our streets become more
livable. Um, as also many people might
know, in East Midtown, property values
over $1,100 per square feet. So, a
single 15 by 20 foot um area represents
$350,000 worth of real estate. And
oftent times through and walking around,
I see a lot of just barren concrete um
that we could be using for our benefit.
Um, so I've uh submitted three draft
resolutions to the board. Uh it's my
first meeting so I hope that's how it
works. Um and I hope we can adopt it. Um
the first one is near-term immediately
fixing what's broken, replacing the 40
plus missing trees where there is an
already a tree bed.
Um and so yeah, asking to have this
completed as soon as possible so they
have the full summer to root. Um, I did
check New York City Parks and they are
planning on planting seven trees in
total this year in our district and they
do not take uh ex uh request to plant
trees. Um, and medium to long term as
the city continues to daylight more
intersections and leaves behind unused
asphalt. We should be converting these
spaces to useful green and public
infrastructure. Um, I'm calling for a
modest goal of converting 7% of parking
spaces annually as a successful
congestion relief pricing has already
reduced 7% of cars in our central
business district. And as a long-term
solution, I'm calling for a bold
redesign of our avenues that put
pedestrians, transit, and community
first. Our streets should reflect 85% of
residents who do not commute by car,
likely more with congestion pricing. Uh,
and even the third avenue redesign
proposal still indicates about 30% of
the streets driving vehicles. Uh, we
should design a street that reflects our
values, not only permanently better. Um,
I'm asking for two-way bike lanes on all
avenues in our district. Um, as many
people know, during commuting hours and
the weekends, bike lanes are already
crowded and given the expanded recently
and on First and Second Avenue, which is
great, but yeah, it's still crowded. Um,
so yeah, and then I was curious too like
how often readers plan on redesigning
these avenues. um if we're still leaving
30% to private vehicles, is it going to
be another 5 years until we reduce it to
20 and then another 5 years until 10?
So, it would be great to just redesign
once um for the future. And yeah, I just
um love living in this area and think
that we should uh build upon uh the
success of congestion relief pricing to
accelerate our transition to a more
equitable and livable city. Thank you.
Thank you for your remarks. We did get
your attachments. uh we will provide
them to the committee. Three minutes is
not enough time to do them justice, but
we will provide them to the to the board
members for further review and we'll
invite you to the appropriate committee
to talk about them.
All right. It does seem like we've
missed an elected official
representative. So, we're with
everyone's seged
to Patrick Hill from
um from Council Member Keith P's office.
Hi everyone. Um I I don't have really
anything to add to our report. Um, aside
from I do want to add one correction.
Uh, so we listed the DA chemole plaza as
our location for the uh, shred event
that we're doing later on this month on
May 31st. That is the intended location.
We're just waiting on confirmation from
the parks department. Um, so as of right
now, that is uh, TBD, but just wanted to
make that correction that uh, we'll get
the uh, confirmed location sent around
to the board as soon as that is
confirmed.
But that'll be happening on May 31st
from 10 a.m. to 1 p.m. Do we have any
questions for Patrick?
I don't think we do. Thank you very
much. Of course. Have a great night.
Yeah. All right. Back to the public
session. Um Cat Hartley. Uh Cat Hartley,
are you here? Cat Hartley, I see you're
online. Cat Hartley is a resident of
this district and wishes to address the
board on the topic of food waste. Miss
Hartley, you have three minutes to make
your remarks. You may begin now. Great.
Thank you. Hi everyone. Good evening. U
my name is Cat Hartley. As mentioned,
I'm a community community member. Um I
wanted to talk today about food waste,
specifically bill 0299, which was
introduced last year. Um and aims to
address the issue of food waste by
reducing civil penalties and encouraging
more food service establishments to
donate leftover food. Over a million New
Yorkers are considered food insecure.
Yet many of these food service
establishments are throwing away over
250 thousand 50,000 tons of food
collectively every year. And so a lot of
this perfectly good food ends up in
landfills um worsening both food
insecurity in the community but also um
climate change as well. There are
existing good Samaritan laws but despite
those um they protect donors from
liability but many food establishments
hesitate to donate because there are
just unclear guidelines and a lot of
logistical hurdles. Um, so this food
waste continues to contribute to rising
greenhouse gas emissions. Um, and then
through my own volunteer work across
burrows, I've seen how food insecurity
impacts communities, but more so just
the stark contrast often between food
waste on the street and food banks
needing more food, often on the same
block. Um, this bill aims to reduce that
food waste and improve food security by
creating a more structured program,
incentivizing businesses to donate that
excess food, um, with waved civil
penalties on certain violations and then
clarifying more of those donation
guidelines so that that fresh food is
reaching hungry New Yorkers in need and
not ending up in landfills. The bill is
currently with the committee on small
business. Um, it's been there since
early last year. I've also been in
contact with Councilman Eric Botcher's
office who sits on the committee um and
just am here today to ask you all to
continue or to start supporting um the
progress of Bill 0299 so that we can
reduce that food waste, fight hunger,
and just build a more sustainable and
equitable city for all New Yorkers.
That's all. Thank you for your time.
Thank you. Thank you very much for your
remarks. All right. Um the next 13
speakers are all speaking on one way or
the other on the same topic. So we will
start with
those. Um Jeremy Barnum, are you here?
All right. Will you please
uh make your remarks? You will have
three minutes. You may begin now. Hi, my
name is Jeremy Barman. I'm
president. I want to focus on narrowly
on the noise issues associated with the
proposed open air rooftop dance qu. The
New York City Noise Code says that, and
I quote, "Unreasonable noise means any
excessive or emotionally loud sound that
disturbs the peace, comfort, or repose
of a reasonable person of normal
sensitivities." The history of the space
matters. When the code says you're a
reasonable person of normal
sensitivities, I can tell you I am
significantly less sensitive than a
normal person. And yet, when the music
was playing on the rooftop before, I
couldn't sleep at all. It was as if the
boom box had been in my bedroom. The
fact that the noise levels routinely
violated the code suggests a steep
uphill climb for the new owner to
establish that the space will be code
compliant. Another reason the dispute is
relevant is that it establishes that 311
is a toothless enforcement mechanism.
Many calls were made and nothing
changed. If the rooftop dance club is
not code compliant, we are facing years
of sleepless nights while we wait for
the city to enforce. So it is imperative
that the developer establish with
certainty that the procedures will be
enforcably code compliant from day one.
In that context, there are some aspects
of the developer's acoustical report
that are quite concerning. The only test
done on the roof was to measure the
ambient noise in order to provide a
baseline against which to measure the
future sound equipment volume. From that
perspective, the report recommends that
the volume be capped at 85 dbc with the
cover open. What this establishes is
that the operator plans to operate the
rooftop dance club with the cover open
and believes that restricting the volume
to 85 dbc will avoid unreasonable noise.
The volume recommendation is based on a
difference between ambient noise and
noise generated for the ambient noise
test ended at 12:30 a.m. But the request
is to operate until 4 a.m. I looked it
up. 85 dbc is about the sound level of
common powered tools loud enough to be
tiring and potentially harmful if you
stay in it for a full workday without
protection. So to put it in plain
English, the developers proposing an
establishment that will produce a noise
level comparable to common power tools
and which would require ear protection
if it were part of the workplace 30 ft
from my bedroom window at 3:30 in the
morning. This is simply not reasonable.
And let's remember we are talking here
about a late night dance club atmosphere
on a rooftop. Isn't the literal point of
such a place thumping base with the roof
open? Wouldn't that be the fundamental
appeal to would be customers? When the
core commercial appeal of an
establishment is in direct conflict with
community interests, the risks are
elevated. We ask that this proposal be
assessed in a computerized manner. now
in order to avoid protracted disputes
after the
fact time is up. Thank you. Good timing.
Thank you for your remarks. Uh and just
for everyone in case it wasn't clear um
the topic of this and uh the next few uh
statements will be on resolution for you
which is on our agenda tonight regarding
liquor licenses for the Gramarcy Park
Hotel. Next person speaking on this is
Caitlyn Macy. Caitlyn Macy is a resident
of Manhattan Community District 6. Uh,
Caitlyn, are you here? Yeah. Hi. All
right. Caitlyn, you have three minutes
to make your remarks on this topic. We
begin now. I also live at Lexington
Avenue across the street from the Tracy
Park Hotel. During the last iteration of
the hotel, open top bar opened with a
retractable roof that played loud music
into the morning hours. This despite the
fact that the hotel stands in an
entirely all sides residential
neighborhood. Unsurprisingly, the bar
was the cause of many noise complaints
to 311 and just as many direct
complaints to the embattled front desk
staff of the hotel. In 2023, I read that
the hotel had been sold to Mr. Morris's
MCR group. I moved to you all to inquire
as to whether CB6 has any guidelines in
place for rooftop establishments. the
way say community board 5 does and I
received an email back from Miss
Barafherty to the negative. I then also
in September of 2023 wrote to Arlene
Harrison in her capacity as head of the
Grammar Park Block Associates expressing
the same concerns. She urged me to put
my concerns in a forwardable letter
which I did. I never heard back. So,
when renovations started, I phoned the
New York State Liquor Authority myself
and was told they had the application
from MCR for multiple additional bars
with long, and by long, I mean until 4
in the morning opening hours. The man I
spoke to explained that they take their
lead from the community board's support
or lack of support for any given
project. So, in April, I approached CB6
expressing my concerns, and my letter
was read out loud at the limited hearing
on April 24th. A hearing Miss Harrison
never told any of her constituents about
despite regular emails about far less
pressing issues such as Samuel Ruggles's
birthday. He's the guy who designed GCY
Park. Even if you view this through the
most charitable lens and chalk it up to
oversight, it remains the case that the
actual limited hearing, Miss Harrison,
in an apparent attempt to undermine my
concerns, is on record dismissing me as
an irrelevant complainant and suggesting
that she had successfully muzzled my
complaint, saying, quote unquote, "That
situation is under control."
I have only 3 minutes to speak. So you
might be asking yourself why I would
take the bulk of the time revisiting the
fact that many of you already know,
namely that Grammarcy Park Block
Associates does not reflect the views of
the constituents it purports to
represent. The reason is that there's a
ripple effect. At least one member of
your board is on record at the April
hearing saying that the support of the
block associates for the hotel is quote
unquote the most important thing in his
decision-making. The state liquor
authority in turn has cited the
community board's support as the most
important thing in their
decision-making. Therefore, the fact
that at the limited hearing, actual
tenants who live on the park were not
represented demands a return of the
proposal to the business affairs and
licensing committee for re-re. Thank
you.
All right. Thank you for those remarks.
Uh, next on the list is Samuel Albert, a
resident of CB CD6 this district who
wishes to speak on this matter. Uh, Mr.
Albert, you have three minutes. You may
begin now. Good evening. My name is
Sammy Albert. I live at 39 BC Park North
and have for 20
years born. I would first like to thank
the transportation committee members for
working to help find solutions to the
traffic issue facing us on 21st Street
because of the construction at 38 Gy
Park North and the closing off of the
traffic and bike lane aggravating an
already poorly passable street. While
disappointed with the lack many
meaningful assistance from the
Department of Transportation, the
transportation committee's insights and
efforts are greatly appreciated.
Second, I wish to comment on the action
being considered for the Grimy Park
Hotel by the business affairs and
licensing committee. I am certainly glad
that the structure is being revitalized
after so many years of standing empty,
but I'm very perturbed in the process by
which the licenses to the hotel are
being considered. There was a single
notice in the door of the building whose
sidewalk is not only covered with
scaffolding discouraging pedestrian
traffic, but also an active site for the
disposal of debris from the building.
This hardly seems to be an effective way
to solicit meaningful community input. I
and my neighbors are concerned about the
proposed changes both indoors and
outdoors as well as the number of
licenses being
requested. While a bar and restaurant
are certainly appropriate to a hotel as
service and convenience to guests, the
planned 240 person quote speak easy
quote in the basement as well as the
private club on the roof and the large
sidewalk cafe are clearly intended to
draw outside patrons. The effect that
this will have on the quiet ne quiet
residential neighborhood of Gracy Park
can be nothing but detrimental.
Lexington Avenue and 21st Street are
both poorly suited for the increased
amount of late night vehicular traffic.
these plan changes will bring. Further,
as the license is being requested for 7
a.m. to 4:00 a.m., I am worried about
late night disruption of patrons that
patrons may bring. None of these issues
were raised at the business affairs and
licensing committee meeting. Indeed,
anyone there who purported to speak for
my neighborhood certainly did not
solicit my opinion or to the best of my
belief and knowledge those of my
neighbors. I therefore request that the
business affairs licensing committee
halt consideration of the license
applications. I ask that they reopen
consideration of the application and
have the opportunity to hear from the
entirety of the neighborhood. That
indeed is the purpose of such meetings.
Thank you.
Thank you for your remarks. Next on the
list is John Moore, a resident of
Manhattan Community District 6. Mr.
Moore, are you here? I am. Thank you
very much for the opportunity to speak.
Uh I live at 44 Grammarcy Park North and
I have three generations in this
building. Uh my 90-year-old mother uh
lives in this building. I have raised my
family in this building for the last 25
years and my son who has also written a
letter alongside mine. I want to concur
with the great comments made by my
fellow neighbors in the uh Grammarcy
Park area and express my opposition not
only to the proposed idea of a rooftop
nightclub outdoor seating for multiple
bars as well as the wine bar that I
understand is part of the 38 Garcy Park
development. Effectively, the result of
these uh liquor establishments at the
hotel on the outside plus a club as well
as the wine bar will tw will turn 21st
Street into a corridor of bar
establishments from Park Avenue all the
way to third. And I clearly wonder why
that is necessary and also what it will
do to the historic character of our
neighborhood. Grammarcy Park is one of
the most important historic
establishments, neighborhoods and gifts
to the city of New York and we are
turning it into a bar corridor. Okay. Um
that is a tragedy. It is the
responsibility not only the business
affair and licensing committee but this
community board to review this
rigorously and incorporate the views of
the neighborhood as well as the
historians who value and want to
preserve the character of this
neighborhood to seriously consider if we
need to transform this great historic
jewel not only for the city of New York
but our entire country into a bar
corridor. We have plenty of liquor
establishments on Park Avenue. We have
liquor establishments and bar
alternatives on Third. Uh what we are
proposing to do, I think, would forever
transform and lose the character of the
neighborhood. And so I concur with my
fellow neighbors who have expressed
their opposition to the idea of an late
night club on top of the hotel as well
as the outdoor bars and the wine bar at
38. Thank you very much. Please
reconsider and establish better due
process both at the business affairs and
licensing committee as well as the
community board process. We the
neighborhoods and New Yorkers do not
need this.
Right. Thank you for your remarks. Next
on the list is Sydney Stein, a resident
of this district. Sydney Stein, are you
here? All
right. You have three minutes to make
your remarks. You may begin now. Thank
you. Uh I'm also a resident with 39 BCY
uh which is the corner of 21st and third
and basically this will echo the
comments made by 18 other people on this
we are already inundated with bars
nightclubs the establishments on Park
Avenue and Third Avenue.
Um, not commenting on the noise from the
music, but I think you also have to
worry about the noise from the traffic.
With these establishments being open
till 3:30, 4:00 in the morning, I'm sure
character will be very heavy with Ubers
and limousines.
Uh, uh, there have been incidents, uh,
thinking about a bar on it was on 22nd
Street between Park and Madison.
Frequently the patients of these places
will use green street as a bathroom
or even themselves of somebody after
effects of drinking for all hours in the
morning. Uh so independent of the noise
from their usage which certainly think
will be serious. We have other
consideration at the street noise and
the traffic as well as public safety.
Thank you J.
All right. Thank you for your remarks.
Next on the list is Abigail Melon, a
resident of this district. Abigail, you
have three minutes to make your remarks.
You may begin now.
My name is Abby Melan and I'm resident
in the
44 neighborhood of John Morris. Um I
speak to the issue of these licensing
for restaurants and bars at the new
hotel. I too am opposed to granting
licenses particularly for activities for
the outdoor seating drinking that is
proposed that is downstairs to the main
street restaurant at the new hotel. Um
and I particularly want to draw
attention to the charter for Grammar
Park when it was drawn up in 1831 by
Samuel Rogals. He specified that it was
to be an entirely
um residential neighborhood, that the
park itself was to be entirely
residential and there were to be no
commercial activities on facing the
park. Um and this facet of the original
charter for Grand Mercy Park has been
reiterated and confirmed by the landmark
commission, the landmarks preservation
commission. Um there was an earlier
request to open a wine bar at 38y Park
in 2020 and that request was turned
down. That request for drivers for a bar
license was turned down for the reasons
of the preservation of the neighborhood
and the reasons of the landmark uh the
landmark commission had continued to
recommend that the charter of Samuel be
observed and be respected. So I too
think that the request for a license for
liquor licences particularly for
restaurants that are going to be at
street level should be returned to the
licensing commission for the
consideration and the board community
board should ado oppose the branding
license for any outside activity from
the military. Thank you very much. Thank
you. Thank you for your remarks. Next on
the list is uh Lewis Mayor, a resident
of this district. Uh Lewis, are you
here?
Lewis Mayor going once, going twice. He
he he is here. I
will I'm promoting him to a
panelist, but he but he is
here. Okay, he should be able to speak.
Hi. All right, Louis, you have three
minutes to make your remarks. You may
begin now. Uh, thank you for uh for
promoting me here, I guess, to panelist.
Um, I guess my question is more about
the way that the hotel is intending to
um deal
with individuals that are that are
either waiting outside. Now, the prior
hotel, like step back, um the current
developers of the hotel have an existing
property in the city um that has meshed
quite well with their um their
neighborhood on the west side of town.
Um, this Gy Park Hotel, um, previously
had nightlife operations in this
neighborhood and did a pretty decent job
of managing the flow in and out of
patrons largely by keeping most of those
patrons inside and managing them within
the lobby of the hotel.
um and just love to
understand and raise for the the
consideration of the board um thoughts
around how that would be managed with
under the current management. Um the the
the concerns raised by the the prior
speaker are relevant from a historical
perspective obviously. Um
and the method in which uh residents are
affected by both vehicular traffic and
foot traffic and noise from revelers in
and out of the night establishments.
um I think are manageable but would have
to be handled carefully um if our if
they're to be done well um as it relates
to how the how the hotel manages patrons
in the neighborhood.
Thank you for those remarks. Uh next
person on the list is David H. Johnson,
a resident of this district. David, are
you in here? Yes, he is.
Mr. Johnson, you have three minutes to
make your remarks. You may begin
now. I've been on the floor building for
25 years. Our concern about this project
is about this project was not conveyed
by the Grammy Park Block Association in
the April 24 meeting. For 100 years,
we've shared the corner of 21st in
Lexington with the Gramarcy Park Hotel
and we hope the hotel and fun Lexington
will remain great neighbors. We
impressed by MCR and its ambition to
build a fivestar hotel. However, we have
serious concerns about the impact of the
hotel on Ramsey Park historic district
and our building. We're worried about
noise, crowding, and other problems.
This isn't a boutique hotel with a cafe.
Proposal is nearly 200 rooms with five
bars, 93 outdoor seats for eating and
drinking. The large rooftop club and a
200 plus person speak easy and seller.
If licensers are approved as proposed,
this hotel could unleash on our
residential neighborhood a serious
public nuisance. There are three
concerns. One is the rooftop club and
the noise adequately discussed by other
speakers. Second is the outdoor dining
and drinking which never existed before.
The request is for 93 seats with service
from 7 a.m. to 4 a.m. This is
unprecedented and not practical within
the property line. plans don't count for
pedestrians, fire department access to
sand
device
servers. Concern is the seller speak
easy again never existed before. We're
worried about queuing and congregate to
enter and exit the sedans club and not
in keeping with the gramy park area. We
ask that community board 6 should
require conversation between MCR and
neighboring buildings in the weeks
ahead. Thereafter, a refined plan should
go back to your business affairs
licensing
committee. The time to determine what's
reasonable is now instead of noise and
other complaints later. Thank you.
Thank you for your remarks. Next on the
list is Brian P. Manning, a resident of
this district. Mr. Manning, are you
here? I am. I'm on Zoom. All right. You
have three minutes to make your remarks.
You may begin now.
Hi, community board 6. Thank you for
taking uh
my statement. My name is Brian Manning.
I'm a resident of one Lexington Avenue.
I'm writing writing in regarding this
item of the liquor licenses for the
Grammarcy Park Hotel. Uh let me first
say Grammarcy Park Hotel holds personal
significance to me. I proposed to my
wife in Grammarcy Park. We were married
at the hotel and years later moved
across the street before its closure. We
often hosted colleagues, friends, and
family at Myelino, the Rosebart, and GPH
was our choice for out of town visitors.
As a local entrepreneur, I support a
revitalized GPH that fits the
neighborhood ethos. That said, we have
serious concerns about the significant
deviations from the prior operations,
including uh large outdoor seating
serving liquor from 7 in the morning to
4:00 a.m. in the morning, a new
subterranean nightclub, open roof events
till 4:00 a.m. The plan lacks details to
avoid negatively impacting the quality
of life in an otherwise quiet
residential area with schools and places
of worship. For example, nothing about
limiting sidewalk footprint, seats,
liquor serving hours, uh protocols for
avoiding sidewalk gatherings, waiting
for nightclub access, soundproofing,
retractable roof closing during uh night
events. We don't believe these concerns
were adequately addressed upon uh
reviewing the replay of the April 25th
business affairs and licensing committee
meeting. Uh we hope community board 6
will lead in resolving the disconnect uh
by requiring immediate conversation
ideally between the developer and the
representatives of the directly
neighboring buildings to discuss and
align on a resolution to these issues
and to send this back to the business
affairs and licensing committee for
review. Thank you.
Thank you for your remarks. Next on the
list is David Bernstein. uh a resident
of this district. Uh Mr. Bernstein, are
you here? Yes. All right. Can we get a
mic to him?
Um thank you for the opportunity to say
how much we welcome back the Grammy Park
Hotel, but not one with these plans.
This redevelopment represents a major
shift for our community. While a Grammy
Park Hotel has long been part of the
area, what's now proposed is not simply
a reopening. This is something new. a
full-scale nightlife and entertainment
complex in the heart of the residential
community. What we do know has been
spotty and frequently changing. That
uncertainty has fueled chatter about
private donations or back room
arrangements with the ground mercy park
association. This all may reflect how
little reliable public information input
there's been so far. To that point,
plans appear to include a rooftop with
retractable roof till 4:00 a.m. Another
200 person plus e easy described are
various as a private members club or
priv or or for public outdoor exceeding
10 ft along uh both Lexington Avenue
21st Street. This isn't just
hospitality, it's volume. For example,
members club adding traffic not only at
night but during busy afternoons, visit
drop offs, deliveries, member lunches.
Taken together, the venue's hours and
sidewalk activity represent the scale
out of sync with this community. Many of
us generally appreciated the way the
previous hotel operated. The staff were
friendly, the door man respectful, the
atmosphere generally quiet neighborly.
It was part of the block rarely
disruptive, but even then the roof path
alone caused real noise issues,
especially late at night. The bar on
Lexington Avenue often drew lingering
crowds, snake past entrances, double bar
cars, and patrons loitering into the
night. We've seen what strong community
advocacy can accomplish. The Ramsey Park
Ocean proudly recalls that his advocacy
with the former cowall club site citing
the need to protect residents from
disruption. It's as if this was moved
and but perhaps waiting. Um this isn't
about opposing change. Indeed, I'm
proposing some. It's about shaping
change in a way that strengthens the
neighborhood rather than overwhelms it
as the community develops and it must be
must develop in the way in the best
traditions of the values CB6 and
particularly the grammar park
association works to protect in so words
to promote public safety crime
prevention historic preservation and
quality of life in that tradition
development shouldn't mean disruption it
should mean growth that fits the context
and investment that represents the
people here to site Jane Jacobs cities
have the capability of providing
function for everybody only because and
only when we are created by everybody.
This isn't about posing change. Change
should be done with not to the
community. All right. Thank you for your
remarks. Next on the list is Robin
Brener, a resident of this
district. Miss Brener, are you here? I
am here. All right. You have three
minutes to make your remarks. You may
begin now. Okay. First of all, thank you
for this platform to for for me to be
heard. This is a very um uh it's a very
emotional heartfelt thing. I'm living in
Grammarcy Park for 40 years. I live at
Fort Lexington. I've been next to the
Grammy. So, I've been been here for
quite some time. The my apartment does
not abut that building. I'm on I would
be kind of like across the
courtyard. My life suffered so because
of the music coming from the Grammy Park
Hotel. I even had their sound people in
my apartment. My windows were shaking.
If they so neat to have music that
travels, I would like for them to maybe
give us some city windows.
um something that would uh help us uh
help me with the sound. I see patients.
I'm in the health field. I see patients
at 8:00 in the morning and there were
days I went to work just stressed and
distressed. I can't tell you how many
times I called the police 311. I called
the hotel and you could just tear your
hair out when you're just falling on
deaf ears. So, I hope that tonight I'm
not falling on deaf ears. No pun
intended. Um, but please please hear us.
This is just and this this is no um
environment for uh a DJ. This is Grammar
Park. It's a it's a gem. It's a treasure
of her neighborhood. So, please let's
preserve
that. Thank you.
Thank you for your remarks. Next on the
list is Jane Studley. um representing
Sage House. Um Miss Studley, are you
here? Yes, I'm here. Okay, you have
three minutes. You may begin now. Okay.
Hi, thank you for everybody listens to
me. I'm the new residents moved to this
area because I think this place is
really beautiful and I love the history
story. So I like the peace and if the
wine bar they open until 4 in the
morning I think is really affect our
older people's life and many in our
building many people they heard it they
were open until 4 in the morning
everybody was upset that's my most in
concern about
it rested I agree all the before the
people they said we have to keep this
area is beautiful and the prosperity
because they have the you you have some
control about it.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you for your remarks. Uh next in
next on the list is Sean Brady who
represents the Grammarcy Park Block
Association. Mr. Brady, are you here?
Yeah. Mr. Brady, you have three minutes
to make your remarks. You may begin now.
the chairman of the quality of life
community park association. I just must
say first of all in reference to the
comments about how the block association
approach this we approach this the same
way that we approach every bar that's
been closed in our neighborhood. I've
been personally going to the boss
committee or the now business committee
meetings for pretty consistently for
about 15 years other than for a couple
years during COVID and in fact the
people whose concerns about night life
on third avenue we've been actively
fighting new bars on third avenue um
since the since the 38 park north bar
that we fought and I was one of the
leaders of that so I'm very sensitive um
to the um to the ISS issues of
nightlight in our neighborhood. I'm also
personally sensitive to the issues of
noise from the rooftop or very smart
noise. I was probably one of the people
who called 31 the most because I'm in 24
and the sound from the rooftop came
directly out to me. So, like I said, we
approached it the same way that we did
with any other provider. When Tyler
Morris uh we found out that he was
taking over the hotel, we approached
him. We approached him with concerns of
the community. Chelsea's concerns, for
example, are being solicited and
forwarded directly to him. Um, and they
did something that no bar has ever done.
When we approached them in the same way,
they commissioned an acoustical report
and they suggested um actual upgrades to
their sound system that will limit the
amount of sound, the volume of their
stereo throughout the hotel at any time,
even if a DJ or a staff member wanted to
turn it up. And they put that in their
stipulations for the license. So
satisfied with the interior, right? We
also looked at the sidewalk. The
sidewalk itself, there's two parts. They
have to get a a liquor license, but they
also have to get a license with
sidewalk. So that's going to be
discussed at a future
bus license meeting. Um, and we'll all
be, you know, um, interested in exactly
how that go. Um the um the most
important thing for us was the
replacement of two really bad operators,
Amy Rosen and Steve Green, who ran the
Grammy Park Block Grammy Park uh hotel
as a nightlife uh um a nightlife
attraction rather than as a hotel. We
looked as we always do at proprietor
proprietor's history and we looked at
the hotels that uh NCR has in New York
and they have no complaints. They have
fitted into the neighborhood as somebody
else has mentioned nicely. This is
supposedly they're they're planning to
cut the number of rooms. Someone
mentioned 200 rooms. That's down from
nearly 400 previous hotel. So that's
also going to be a good impact on
traffic in the neighborhood which I
think will um largely offset the
increase in traffic from uh from the
bars uh that they'll have in the hotel
which prior bars had hotel the prior
hotel had bars um and they were very
rockets everybody knows. Um so we
approached it the same way we did talk
reached out to the proprietor our
concerns were discussed and met and we
present in our conclusion at the
business license here as discussed I
hear everybody's concerns everybody that
is time and I completely understand and
I understand and um and that is
time one person that suggest suggested
that I would pay off another hotel
developer who I never even met until the
last meeting. I really want to say
you'll earn my
lawyer. All right. Uh next on the list
is Donald Bernstein, uh representative
of the applicant uh in question. Uh Mr.
Bernstein, are you here? Yes, I'm here.
All right. You have three minutes to
make your remarks. You may begin now.
Thank you. Good evening everybody. My
name is Donald Bernstein. I'm the
attorney for Tyler Morris and MCR
Development. Uh first I want to thank
the business affairs committee for its
unanimous support of our application and
the tremendous enthusia and enthusiastic
endorsement from the Grammy Park Block
Association. The association in doing
its due diligence has recognized the
tremendous importance of reopening this
iconic hotel and expressed their
complete confidence in Tyler and the MCR
team. I have been practicing in this
area of law for many, many years and I
have rarely seen such fervent and
passionate support from a community
organization as we have here. This hotel
has had a liquor license for 90 years.
It has had a stream of owners over the
past 60 years or so. Uh MCR, the current
owner, is the third largest hotel owner
and operator in the country with a
portfolio that includes the TWWA Hotel
at JFK and the Highline Hotel at 10th
Avenue. It is probably the most
qualified and experienced hotel owner
and operator in the Grammycy Park
Hotel's history. Prior owners of the
past 25 years that have apparently
created some issues with the community
have included nightlife operators such
as Steven Greenberg, uh, boutique hotel
operators Ian Shrager and real estate
entrepreneurs who are not hotel
operators. Um, MCR, however, has a long
history of owning many, many hotels
throughout the country and will be
operating a five-star hotel. We met with
your business and affairs committee last
month. We complied with all of their
requirements. We posted notice of the
meeting on the hotel front door in
Lexington Avenue. We sent a photo of
that to the community board office. We
completed uh the questionnaire,
including all the operational issues.
That was all before the committee. In
fact, as someone noted, the committee
had a letter in opposition to the
application. That was discussed. The
concerns were discussed. So, the
committee did do its job. In terms of
anyone missing that meeting, you also,
as you know, post your agenda on your
website. Anybody in the community that
is concerned always can check that
website and know that a matter is being
uh discussed at a committee meeting. Uh
Tyler attributes great importance to the
character and quality of his hotel
operation. Uh it is not a dance club.
This is not a nightclub. The hotel has
had a 4 a.m. license going back to at
least the 1980s if not earlier. Uh
towards that end of ensuring the quality
of the hotel, he commissioned a full
acoustic study by Alan Firestein who's
the preeminent sound acoustician of the
city well known to the state liquor
authority. Um that exhaustive study was
provided to your committee and it
includes two pages of recommendations to
ensure that the sound will not
negatively impact neighbors. And even as
important, if not more important, um you
have to keep in mind that right below
the rooftop and above the restaurant are
guests paying upwards of $1,000 or more
maybe for guest rooms. And the last
thing any experienced operator such as
Tyler Morris would do is shoot himself
in the foot by creating that would
disturb them. Thank you that we thank
you and we hope we have your support as
well. All right. Thank you.
Um we have now gotten to all of the
speakers who duly submitted
registrations for the public session by
the deadline for tonight. That concludes
the speakers list for the public
session.
Bang. Moving on. Minutes from the April
9th full board meeting were distributed
to board members by the board office. If
there is no objection, we will adopt the
minutes as drafted. Board members, if
you object to adopting the minutes, you
may raise your
hand. Seeing no objections, the minutes
from the April 9th full board, excuse
me, meeting are adopted. They will soon
be available on the CB6
website. We are saying goodbye to four
members of the board who will be greatly
missed. They have made amazing
contributions to our community. Um, and
those four-time board members um will be
moving on to serve the community in
other ways. David Loenstein, who joined
us in 2023, is moving and going on to
other things. Libya Shrenik is not
available to join us this evening, but
has promised to come back to say goodbye
the next month. Majed Abdul Samad joined
the board in 2022 and has been a huge
influence on our land use and waterfront
committee, but he will also serve as a
public member of that many of that
committee. So, he is not going away.
Susan Steinberg joined the board in 20
in 2006 and has served on many of our
committees, most recently as the calm
experience voice on a business affairs
and licensing committee and the land use
and waterfront committee. Susan has
generously agreed to stay on as public
member of our land use and waterfront
committee to help us with our advocacy
for the Beth Israel site. Susan wanted
to say a few words. Susan,
you're muted. Susan,
thank you very much, Sandy. It really
has been a very quick 19 years.
Some of you may remember this name, but
when I joined in 2006, Lyall Frank was
the chair of the board. He went on to
become a judge. And the uh district
manager was Tony Carina, whom Jesus
supplanted. So, I've been around, but
and I know that when I first joined, I
thought, "Oh my god, it's such an August
body and they deal with such significant
issues." And what was the topic of my
first meeting? Herb cuts. And I thought,
oh
well. But I went on to learn that there
are really a lot there are issues big
and small. And this uh community board,
any community board is really the first
line of defense uh for and and of
protection for the people who live here.
It's really a very important job. I've
learned a lot and I've made some great
uh relationships. We have wonderful
people both new and old or older on the
committee. Our electives are really
first rate and their staff are terrific.
So, I've enjoyed everything like an old
soldier. I'll just kind of quietly fade
away except for land use and waterfront.
And I'm I'm Thank you very much for
allowing me to say this goodbye.
We're going to miss you, Susan. I have
her own committee.
Yes, some of us are lucky enough to join
her the committee she's on. Um, but
welcome to the eight new members. Um, I
would like each of you to give a very
brief introduction and let us know one
important thing we should know about
you. We're not going to use the timer,
but you can see that we appreciate
brevity at this point in the meeting.
Um, so first off we have Liz
Burr. I think Liz is online. Yep. Yes, I
am. Here I am. Hello.
Hi. So, what one thing you'd like us to
know about you?
Um, let's see.
I have been living in Kips Bay for 16
years uh in the same unit and I've been
a renter this whole time, but I really
love the community.
Right. Okay. Thank you. And brevity was
good
there. Daniel Bernstein.
Everyone. Whoops. We need the mic or
they won't hear you at home.
Thank you.
Hi everyone. Daniel, I've lived in the
district for a year and a half now. Um,
and I'm passionate about environmental
issues and sustainability in the city.
Great. Um, Kate Kennedy.
Wait, wait for the mic or they won't
hear you. Wait for the folks on Zoom.
Um, I'm Kate Kennedy. I um really I was
really surprised but really delighted to
be able to join this board and I look
forward to learning and working um with
all of you or some of you. Um, and I
have three kids so I'm most interested
in making spaces for them to play.
Okay. Will Perry
Will Perry
um I work in housing and financial
coaching and so both those things are
really important to me. Um but a lot of
the stuff is really important to me.
where we have Omari
um who cannot be with us this evening
traveling but it was short notice so
thank you for everybody who did come
Valero
and Cat's already attended a meeting in
person to call me
out neighborhood almost 10
years it's something I aspire to and One
fun fact, uh yes, I did go to um
committee meeting for this, but I am
very very invested in healthcare
justice. Um so that is the committee
that I was eager to invest in. Thank you
very much.
Great. Um David Woods.
Yes, my name is David Woods. My spouse
told me to uh listen more and shut
up. Basically, I'm very passionate about
mobility and developing cities on the
urban planning. So, it's cities and
mine. Thanks.
Um and Sao.
[Music]
Hi everyone. My name is Shuya and I'm a
resident in Sky. I work as a
preservationist and I look forward to
being with everyone here. Thank you.
Great. We will be holding training
sessions for the new members soon. Um
I'm not sure we've got a date yet, but
definitely that's coming coming up. Uh a
very brief report. The state gaming
commission is holding a excuse me is
holding a virtual public scoping session
on the draft scope of work for the
Freedom Plaza Casino proposal. Oh god.
On May the 20th, which is next Tuesday.
Um it's from 5:00 to 7:00. It's it's
virtual, but we do have a resolution
against locating a casino on this site,
which is 1st Avenue between East 38th
and 41st Streets. So, we will be
preparing a response based on that
resolution. Um, but the public is also
welcome to submit their opinions and um
the office will send that information
out to everyone. It's on the CB6 website
now on the homepage and in the events
page and it'll be in the eblast coming
out later this week. So, do let anyone
know who's interested in giving some
testimony. It can be written or um or I
believe the written testimony is
actually due on June 3rd, but the verbal
testimony is next week on Tuesday. Okay.
And there's a lot of documentation
that's associated with their proposal.
So, it's good to read through understand
what it is and
uh we'll we'll move on from there. Um
the other thing is we will have our
first meeting this week with the
department of city planning and our
elected officials on locating affordable
housing and community board 6 and this
is part of the spark uler agreement. So
it's our first meeting uh with them. Uh
our district manager Jesus Pres will now
give a report. Thank you. Uh welcome to
all the new members and welcome to all
the members of the community who are
here on issues that they are passionate
about. In the interest of brevity, I
will say one thing. Um, if you are not
signed up for our newsletter, please go
to our website and sign up. It is the
best way to be informed about all the
meetings that we have coming up. Uh, or
consult bookmark our website and uh you
don't have to look at it every day, but
every once in a while take a look, make
sure that there's nothing on the agenda
of one of our meetings that you are
interested in. But please, please take
some of our flyers, go to our website,
sign up for our newsletter. Um, you'll
be glad you did. Thank you.
Yes, definitely. Welcome. It's nice to
see some the seats filled in our in our
meeting. Um, we've now arrived our
committee at our committee reports and
resolutions. A reminder that the same
rules stated at the beginning of the
meeting apply. Members of the public,
please note that during this section of
the meeting, we only recognize questions
from members of the board. The CB6 staff
emailed the digital ballot to all
members. Please click on the link in
your email um to go to the ballot.
Select your name from the drop- down
list and select your vote on each
resolution as it is presented. Do not
submit it until later in the meeting
after the final resolution has been
presented. The assumption would be that
you're going to listen to the discussion
and then vote. Um at the end of the
meeting, please submit after you've
indicated all your votes on your ballot.
You will not be able to submit the
ballot unless you vote on every
resolution. If you plan on abstaining,
you can select abstain, but an
abstension counts as a negative
vote. Um, final vote counts will be
announced after the second roll call. If
any part of our voting procedure is
unclear, please raise your hand and um,
we can address it. It'll be a bit
interesting maybe for the first time for
the the new members, but we'll anybody
who needs help, please feel free. Okay,
first up is land use waterfront. Gabe
Turzo, vice chair. Okay. Hello
everybody. Make this quick. We are
culminating our water our water club
process here. We're asking for a park on
the side of the water club. Part of our
ongoing beautifification on the
waterfront. We're asking for an interim
activation that can be done quickly.
While EDC plans something more
substantial, we're asking for safety
features, neighborhood amenities, um,
interaction with the water, a bit of
elevation, and most importantly, a self
toilet. Any questions?
Okay. If there's no objection, we'll now
vote on the resolution. Please mark your
digital
ballot. Okay.
Next up, Gabe.
Okay, this the disposition of 455th
Avenue disposition of city man to 45th
Avenue is celebrated. Uh this is really
pro for we already supported the
project. Um and I urge you to supporters
this is just a
and we'll actually be voting on this at
burough board tomorrow if it passes. And
we we passed the same thing unanimously
for Spark previous.
All right. If there's no objection,
we'll now vote on the resolution. Please
mark your ballots.
And do you have a report, Gabe?
Actually, uh I was going to talk about
the meeting on
20. Oh, sorry. That's not
yet. Uh I wait my reporting interest in
time.
Good evening. Uh we have a couple uh
resolutions from transportation tonight.
Uh the first
is a request for a no parking sign uh
that's currently located in front of 39
GC Park North. We're asking DOT on
feedback from uh the uh the residents
and the board of 39 GC Park North. We're
asking for that sign to be relocated. uh
about 40 ft west. Right now it is east
east uh right now is uh to the left or
west of the fire hydrant. And it is
creates a confusing situation where
people believe they uh can park in front
of the uh the fire hydrant. So we're
asking for it to be moved outside of the
fire hydrant. No parking
area parking in front of the building in
front of the fire.
Okay, if there's no objection. Oh, I'm
sorry. Um, Sandre Lop has her hand
raised. Sandra, um, I thought some ways
it said they wanted to make the no
parking 30 feet. Did I get that right?
It wasn't just about the fire hydrant,
but it was having a fairly decent amount
of space.
They originally gave the to the
committee there
was their main concern was um asking for
to make it clear that there's no parking
allowed in front of the prior there was
originally a request for signage no
parking signage uh when they came to the
committee uh but after discussing with
um with the at committee they didn't
feel that no parking signage was
appropriate and we reached a compromise
of moving the existing fine that as
parking regulations uh to better clarify
the parking situation for the parking.
So, it's just about the no parking sign.
It's not about increasing the uh the
space. That's all I'm asking. Uh yeah,
this general sign. It wouldn't change
anything with the
Okay. We do have the next resolution
though does pertain to some parking
regulation changes. That's unrelated to
this one. Okay. But just my comment is
all we keep doing is losing public
parking space and that's very
problematic because the cost of not
having that for the middle class is a
disaster. So that's my comment.
Okay. Um, oh, I'm sorry, Larry.
Just
encouraging in reading this summary and
listening. Um, just a tad confused. So,
we are describing the area in front of
the fire
hybrid and what parking regulation is
applicable there.
Uh so so the the current sign I forget
exactly uh what it says. It uh I believe
it designates the street cleaning hours
and the meter parking. So we're asking
for that time to be moved uh to the
other side of the the hydrant. So that's
not confusing that people believe that
they can that that area in front of the
parking sorry the area in front of the
hydrant is subject to those the open
hours and the regulations. Okay. So I
think we need to be I think we need to
be clear that the parking regulation in
front of a fire hydrant is no standing
no barking
and 15 ft on either side of the fire
hydrant.
Yeah.
Okay. Um if there's no objection, we'll
now vote on the resolution. Please mark
your ballots.
Uh so the next resolution we have is in
uh pertains to the same block, same
corner uh but slightly different issue.
Uh so the residents of uh the
neighborhood have been coming to the
last two transportation committee
meetings to express concerns they've had
around construction at 38 Grand Park
North and concerned with congestion um
and not a vehicle. So we'll be uh
blocking potentially blocking the
roadway and I have been blocking the
roadway uh related to the demolition and
forthcoming reconstruction of 38 RC park
north. Um, in order to move out their
concerns about traffic on that corner,
uh, we, uh, are recommending that the
Department of Transportation
temporarily, uh, restrict parking on the
north side of that corner, uh, to
temporarily not allow parking, um,
basically from uh, that fire hydrant to
the uh, to the corner. It's
approximately three parking spaces uh to
allow for um vehicle to be able to get
through that um that area while there's
construction activity construction
vehicles.
Yeah.
Isn't park or in that area old no
standing?
uh much of the block is uh the block
that we're requesting to change does
have meter parking there on the corner
but west of those much of the pretty
much the entire block is is no parking
um residents uh and I have observed uh
that those signs are uh largely ignored
by folks using uh parking placards uh
primarily the NYPD precinct that's down
the block. Um, so while there's
technically no parking on the block, it
is almost always.
So, so why
boing there should be
enforced signs not going to help because
people not having ticket for instance or
the department of transportation is not
uh important parking. So whether you put
more signs up, I don't think it can make
any difference. Well, so just to be
fair, there is parking. This is parking
is allowed in this area where we're
asking for it to be changed. No parking.
It's near parking today. I share your
concern that it will be ignored though.
We try and it can't be enforced if if
there's no signage indicating as such.
Yeah.
All right. Do we have any other
questions on this?
Okay. All right.
If there's no Oh, I'm sorry.
Jason.
Um, okay. If there's no objection, we'll
now vote on the resolution. Please mark
your digital ballot.
And while you're doing that, I have a
report. Um, I am very excited that the
Cleo Bridge statue path uh will be open
on the roadway of the bridge on Sunday
uh at 9:00 a.m. I will be there.
uh walking across it. Um so this um the
committee and the board has advocating
this for some time. It's been about
three years in the making. So I'm
excited to see this finally coming
forward. Um although the city council
has been considering a universal
daylighting bill. Uh this is uh
effectively would uh restrict parking uh
at intersections um that there would be
no parking lot within 20 ft of an
intersection uh to increase visibility
uh for uh pedestrians walk and make
intersection safer. Um all of our
um city council representatives, council
member powers and council member Rivera
have sponsored this bill. There was a
hearing a couple weeks ago at city hall
on this that I was able to testify in
support on behalf of the board given our
recent resolution in support of that.
Um, also wanted to update on uh sending
a note to the Department of
Transportation uh to request seings and
callers to be installed at the plaza in
Fifth Bay at 2nd Avenue and 32nd Street.
Uh we recently met with the board from
Kate Towers. They were in support of
activating the phase. Um and so we've
gone ahead and asked D to help make that
space a bit more robust and usable. Uh
and then lastly, the committee is
extremely excited that DOT is planning
to present uh to us on a protected a
protected bike lane on Third Avenue uh
in our next month meeting and that will
be uh covering the area from 59th Street
South to 24th Street. all the funding at
the airport.
Great. Thank you. Uh next we have Stu
Desert, chair of public safety and
sanitation.
The first resolution I think we're not
and just if if anyone would like to see
any of the visuals that go along with
the resolution, we do have them. But I
thought in the spirit of the time we if
there were any questions we might just
proceed.
Okay. If there's an objection, we'll now
vote on the resolution. Please mark your
ballot.
And for the visuals, you can always
watch the uh the zoom of the public
safety and sanitation. There's some
interesting images that that have been
done.
Hey, we have a second uh resolution on
the agenda. Uh at the time that the
resolution on discovery was reported out
of committee, the governor had been
holding the state's budget um in uh as a
hostage in a quest for the legislature
to make substantial changes to the law
and evidence. Um after negotiations the
governor lauded the changes but when the
text of the legislation was released it
was obvious that the legislature the
legislature held firm uh and the
amendments are quite modest uh to agree
to agree then the language of the
resolution was superseded by events. uh
the committee might still want to
support some complimentary legislation
and um and legislation that would help
both district attorneys and defend
council. Uh and the committee might also
want to voice a position should the
governor's proposals revivify. So,
madame chair, I seek unanimous consent
uh to recommit the resolution to the
public safety and sanitation committee.
Um any objection? Are there any
objections? Seeing none, please go
ahead.
Okay, for those of you regarding your
ballots, um, just mark whatever for that
resolution and we will strip it out
later.
All right. Next, we have business
affairs and licensing. Anton Mhler is
chair.
Right. Bundle
A, L, M, and N, which are all
um
alteration, the S SOA or sidewalk
dining.
um all the restaurants in question that
comply with all the necessary paperwork.
They do have sidewalk face but they do
need to have this alteration
um licensing as we all know. And you may
have a liquor license for selling wine,
beer,
cider inside, but as soon as you put up
a an
outside vending area, either on the
sidewalk or on the Broadway, you have to
get an operation license from the state
liquor authority. Uh we have no
problems. These are all unanimously
approved by members of the committee.
And I would suggest that this is the
best way to handle those particular
alteration licenses. So just what were
the ones again please? A A L N and N.
Okay. And so for for the new members, we
quite often do this. If it's something
that's not contentious, we just bundle
it and if there's no discussion, just go
ahead and vote.
I would like to also make resolution to
bundle B through K which are halls that
were have a license. We recommended
approval uh in our voting. uh they all
fill up appropriately the P
um requirements in terms of schematics
and other questions regarding the
distances from the curb and number of
seats. We have no issues with that and
they were all voted unanimously by the
committee to be granted.
Which
one? Sorry,
Kevin. Second parliamentary. Uh, so I
second both. Okay. I'm sorry. All right.
Then Pat, you had a question. Yeah. As a
new member and clearly did not hear. Um,
I did look up the cafe
uh policy. I'm just curious when we're
saying
bundling
everything that is it a temporary
situation or is it long term and it's
such
kind or that's something to be held at
the next meeting.
Well, Anton can explain. Yeah. Reason we
ask for bonding is because all these
nonentemptions, no problem. And they all
refer to the same kind of approval.
sidewalk cafe license or alteration
license toward state authority. The
sidewalk cafe
licenses are recommendations for
approval to the department of
transportation which has uh perview over
sidewalk cafes and roadway cafes. Uh B
through K are all sidewalk cafe
licenses.
All the appropriate documentation was
sent to the DOT which does send it to us
with unfortunately very little time to
review them, but we do review them all
and they're very comprehensive and it's
the uh setup of what they were doing in
the past when the pandemic uh hit us.
These types of sidewalk um licenses uh
and roadway licenses are far more
temporary and far more um aesthetic to
the neighborhood.
So yes, this is a long-term license, but
they have submitted documentation and if
you're interested in the documentation,
you can go back to the Zoom of the
meeting and it is it is point of clarity
I did. Okay. Um, and it was the question
about longevity, like how long is this
long-term, how long is the license for?
Four years. Four years.
Thank you.
Okay.
Um, I'd like to bundle OP, QR, and S
together. These are applications for
bigger licenses.
We review them all and they're all
unanimously approved by the committee
members and they're all restaurants
which we are with we are familiar with
from the neighborhood.
Okay, we have a second.
All right, so please go ahead and mark
your ballots
now. Um D resolution of no comment
regarding alteration for wine beer
der incorporated during business the
Ryan diner and grill uh situation came
up that we had looked at this at not the
last meeting prior meeting and found out
that their liquor license had
expired. So, we couldn't approve or
recommend an
alteration for an outdoor cafe license
for selling liquor if they don't have an
original license to begin with. We found
out the same
day that we were meeting that the state
authority had granted them a
liberal
for their restaurant. Um, since we
didn't have enough time to really get
into this, we felt that we didn't want
to
uh not give Orion Diner long
time restaurant in the neighborhood uh a
uh no comp resolution. So rather
than approving, we send this no comment
to safe liquor
authority and uh again this was
unanimous. Um we had no issues like the
Orion diamond rule. The only problem is
their
license for the reason but the apparent
oversight was allowed to lapse but is
now in order and uh we would have no
issue with alteration application.
Larry clarification um you mentioned
that they received an approval for a
full liquor license. Well, they already
had one was last and between our let's
see our March meeting and the special
meeting we had
yesterday, they were able to regularize
that as of yesterday morning. And so as
of this evening, they have a full liquor
license. And this um resolution the wine
license to the full liquor license.
This refers to the alteration.
So required what are they what are they
going to propose to operate on the
sidewalk?
their full liquor license.
It's a wine license. I'm sorry. What was
the question?
In other words, a full on premises
liquor license or is it a wine license?
This is wine. Okay. And that's what's
been approved,
right? Okay. Um, is there a possibility
of a of a of an amendment so that we
could uh be consistent with the status
quo and support
There's a there's a tight there's a
tight timeline on that and we spoke with
the um SLA on this about whether they
would what they think about this
language. Um and they're perfectly fine
with it. Um I'd be I'd be happy to move
or support
Larry. I don't think we need to. I think
we can just proceed the way the
committee has agreed to do it. Unless
there's, you know, any particular
benefit to that, I'm not sure there is.
Anton, would you prefer to proceed?
State authority paid. Okay, no problem.
So, but it's not a concern. Okay. Thank
you. Okay. The last one is a resolution
objection for new application retail
based for on premises liquor license for
M4 Gy Park Hotel LLC and for Grammy Park
Hotel Tenant LLC and MCR Property
Management LLC DBA to be determined at
two Lexington Avenue 52 Gy Park
North
Daer Lexington Avenue. I know we had a
number of comments from members of the
community. I also read all the letters
that were sent to the uh office this
afternoon after
3:00. Um I respectfully
respectfully submit that we did our due
diligence. I feel the hotel operator is
a great operator. So did the committee.
We had two members of the community
representing that this would be a good
thing for the community as a whole and
um the hotel operator appears to have
done all due diligence in terms of sound
and um I'm not familiar with that area
and quite
frankly we might not consider Lexington
Avenue a restaurant card or if you go to
the other side of the park ing place.
Every building has a restaurant. So, I'm
a little concerned
that residents feel that this would
change the character of the
neighborhood. I know that the the
National Art Club has more than 150
events every year in which there are
people coming in and out the sea park
south. So
um I feel felt that the hotel in
addition to the neighborhood and that
they would operate
uh under
the current laws of the state labor
authority and do which by the way has
the purview over sidewalk and roadway
cafe of the
SLA.
Any questions? Just see.
Yes. I'd like to speak to that rooftop
bar. It I I live on Grammarly Park and I
live with that for years. It was a
horror. I cannot tell you. I could not
believe this at this meeting. It might
come up again. I guess over co it was
gone. It was an ongoing horror every
weekend. the disregard for the
community, the way it disrupted our
lives, the noise. You can't have an open
bar and think there's no noise. I
couldn't believe how far the noise
traveled. 311 didn't do anything.
Nothing did anything. We live with that.
The thought of it returning is a horror.
These community members showed up
because they have lived with it. I live
with it. And all I could say, it was an
unbearable experience. The arrogance,
the sense that this is a commercial
district, which it is not. The sense
that nobody cared about the residents,
the sense that you had kids, the noise
started, it went on. The thought of it
going till 4:00 a.m. 11:00 a.m. it was
11:00 p.m. It was
unbearable. But that would be all I can
tell you, it was a disgrace. An absolute
disgrace. So to make that parallel to
the you know the the uh you know the
national arts club irrelevant it's an
irrelevant comparison the all the places
on Irving nobody violated the privacy
the respect for the neighborhood the way
that hotel
did it would be unbearable if
we talking about prior owner of the
hotel not the current owner I understand
that but you know you give people a
license and You hand away power that you
cannot believe and noise travels and
that that or whatever the music was,
they were blasting it. These folks who
spoke knew what they were talking about
to suggest we now have godsend. You
know, I'm a little bit cynical when it
comes to that kind of, you know,
commercialization. Go make people
accountable once you've signed it away.
It's an interesting dilemma. Okay. I can
only tell you what 311 did, which is
nothing. either of your comments. Well,
I wanted to um we you know, we spent a
lot of time handling this uh application
and um I was under the impression I
think most of us were that it was we
addressed the issue of noise. So, we we
talked about it um probably for 20 30
minutes. Uh the impression that I got
was that in the past it had been a
concern. Um but there were going to I'm
pretty sure that we you know we
discussed the fact that we that the
noise would be limited. Yes. So and also
I I just
what's your control mechanism? Not to be
cynical. How do you control it once you
start it? Cassandra please wait till you
I know. I'm sorry. Thank
you wants to go. Yeah.
While a rooftop bar is open, there's
also an enclosed area that that covers
the rooftop bar.
Okay. So, I'm going to go on the record
again. I didn't think I had to this
week, but here we
are. There's issues around these
licenses that were running through
committees, and I know you guys are
doing a it's a hard job. There's a lot
of things you have to do, but I heard
from a lot of folks today. I'd like to
think I'm listening to the community and
it seems this rooftop bar is a big part
of this. Can't we go back and talk to
these people again and bring these
people in? Let's have a conversation
because we're just alienating an entire
neighborhood to an establishment that
could actually and they have admitted
could be very good for their
neighborhood. So to me, it's more how
we're doing
stuff. Maybe not how it ends, but anyone
who's even walked past a rooftop bar,
come up, knows what that means. So I'm
just on the record that I think there's
an issue with this resolution. I think
we need to hold off, get more
conversation, bring in the owners, have
a meeting. Let's get a win. So everyone
feels good about this project. That's
how things get done and that's how
things are
successful. So that's me on the record.
Is Mr. Bernstein
still Bernstein?
I'm I'm sorry I didn't attorney. Donald
attorney. Yes.
He's here. What? I don't think he's
He's here. He is here. Keith, do you
Kevin? Yes, I'm here. Sorry, Kevin has
his hand up, please. Thank you. The word
relevance was mentioned. What is
relevant and I know that the committee
knows this is the Freehand Hotel. They
have a open air bar restaurant. They
serve drinks to a certain hour. We went
down this road before where we made sure
that the noise was mitigated. We know we
heard from somebody who lived right
across the street. So I think there's a
case study here to pretend this is the
first rooftop top bar. Not only is it
not the first, the other one is what
four blocks off Lexington. Can we
address that Anton? Because again
there's a lot of due diligence and
discussion went around and I believe
they're now in a happy space there.
Thank you.
Anton.
Well, I thought the sound
um report that was made by this uh
expert lay out very clearly
that the sounds that coming from this
rooftop bar were about or less than the
ambient noise of the street.
So, uh, I'm a little confused as to we
shouldn't conflate what happened four
blocks away with what's happening over
here, what happened five years in the
past. I I think what Kevin's saying is
that we actually dealt with a situation
where there were complaints and managed
to have it be acceptable to the
community. and and the the providers did
set up sound barriers did give
u thought to not playing music after a
certain time and we didn't have any
issues for years to do that.
Sorry, we're in discussion up here.
Steve, do you want to say something?
When I heard the speakers tonight on on
both sides, I thought that they were
willing to have a dialogue that they
didn't yet feel they had. Um, I would
like to make a motion, but Anton, I'm
going to ask you to comment on this
first. I would like to move um to
recommmit this to your committee uh and
to let all the parties communicate each
other.
And all right, I seem to feel again from
the letters I seen over here that it
only emanates from one or two buildings
around there, not the rest of the
neighborhood.
And I I'm
sorry, two Lexington, seven
Lexington are the primary
I
received
and may please if we could just have one
pass away.
Okay.
All right. Um I would like to recommend
that we ask for a discussion between the
community and the the hotel owner. And
um I understand that the next bulk
meeting has an extremely long agenda. So
we don't necessarily want to burden
them, but if there can be this meeting
and I know that I'm pretty sure that the
uh the owner of the hotel is willing to
speak with the community, they have done
that. So we can ask them to meet with
the community and come back just have a
a brief review of this at your next
meeting. Right. And you're right. The
owner did meet with So let him meet with
let them meet with the rest of the
community.
Um I just want to add some procedural
information as the former business of
chair uh business affairs chair um when
all these issues originally were being
dled about 10 years ago. Um and you know
coincided with COVID when finally shut
down. So this area has been closed for
about six years now almost. Um, a vote
tonight doesn't automatically give the
license to be out. There's still a form
where the city council has to vote on
it. So, I think we have enough
information tonight to actually vote on
this and can have the stipulation. I
think Mr. Let me let me finish listen to
you. I didn't say anything. Let me
finish my thought, please. Where we can
take the vote on it with the information
that has been prevented. If you want to
say no, say no. If you want to say yes,
say yes. But we can ask for a
stipulation. Mr. Bernstein is here as
well that any uh positive vote has to
include consistent dialogue with the
residents, not a one-off, consistent
dialogue with the residents. And I agree
with Kevin, we've had this issue in the
past where we've actually gotten it to a
place where people in the city brought
it back. Um so I think uh we have the
ability to do that. I think the vote
that we take tonight does not preclude a
meeting between the residents and the
business operator themselves. You can
have that independently. You can you can
we can have that be a stipulation in
this resolution as well. So if you are
committed to that, if you as you have
mentioned that you want to have that
conversation, we can stipulate that
right now and vote it in the affirmative
to make sure that if they do not meet
with you, if they do not have that, then
that resolution is voided. So I would
suggest that half um in order to make
sure that it's accountable to everyone
and that everyone's interest is being
represented. And can I ask a question?
I'm sorry this is just for board
members. Oh, are you a board member?
Sorry, I didn't mess up.
I thought I was a
mean. I'm sorry about that, but having
done this for many years, that's
useless because unless you have them
before you make the
vote, nothing is going to happen. Even
if they do meet
So the teeth is if they they come bring
it back. I know you guys are all
busy. Put it on on um actually do what
they ask cuz I thought you know I think
that makes sense from a newbie
perspective that's done this for 40
years. The only way to get a real vote
and a voice from us to the city council
is if we understand the real issues and
that they do it. I don't think they
understand the real issues
um yet because they're not communicating
to the ne the whole neighborhood and
even if it's a block away that doesn't
matter. That's just my my um question.
You're not supposed to shut up, but
so let we'll let Kyle respond just No.
So I totally understand. Um and I'm just
kind of giving a little example of you
know being the business and the chair of
the board previously too about how uh
strategically that we can do this to
make sure that it actually moves forward
in an appropriate way. Um, but I think
also at the root of this too, and you
know, this has been mentioned before, is
that we can't
hold applicants to the sins of former
operators. I think that's a big big
issue here is that a lot of these issues
are with a former applicant, a former
operator and to set a precedent. But let
me finish, sir. Sir, sir, let me finish.
Let me finish. Thank you. Please. This
is a discussion for the community board.
Thank you.
Is that a precedent where we're holding
new applicants who have had nothing to
do with the issues that you've
experienced? And I'm not saying that
your issues have not been experienced. I
think we have all recognized that and we
prioritize that in this resolution and
with this new applicant and we're
willing to put it in writing that this
needs to be proactive, this needs to be
preventative and it needs to go forward
in a way that is responsible to the
community. But the root of a lot of
these comments are because of the
previous operator. And to set a
precedent, we're holding new businesses
in an area when we're talking about
empty storefronts, vacant buildings, uh,
and why aren't they being filled up?
It's for reasons like this where we get
good operators. This operator has
operated a bunch of hotels in this
district, topnotch hotels, and have
shown and have shown that they do that.
Excuse me, please. I'm a board members.
Um and so and so that's you know if we
have to we'll empty the room. Please let
us let us have our discussion. And so I
would just urge the board members to
keep that in mind uh that while there
are issues that exist is not with this
applicant who's before us who has
committed to not committing misers. And
if I could just recommend that we have a
motion on the floor to alter the the
resolution. Um, I will second Pal's
motion. Okay. And then we need to vote
on that and then I think after that we
will vote on sending it back to
committee. I'm sorry to interrupt but I
keep raising my hand and I think you
don't see it. We do see it. We've got
lots of hands raised but we're going to
move ahead with a vote on whether we are
going to alter the existing resolution
or not. Okay. So let's um I think
unfortunately we if we can do a show of
hands that's the easiest. If it's close
we'll
The amendment. The amendment is to alter
the existing um resolution to include a
stipulation that the owner must meet
with the residents prior to the vote by
the city council.
Why can't we table this? I'm sorry. At
this point, this degree, we've already
we've had we've had this motion
presented. will if this does not pass we
will vote on tableabling or not
tableabling but sending back to the
committee. Can I ask what city council
is is vote is there? This is a state
liquor license. So the city council has
no role in this. So the city council
gives approval don't they don't they
vote for dining out NYC applications but
this is a pure state. This is a pure
liquor license. So the city council is
not going to weigh on this. Okay. So
let's let's go back. Um, let's vote on
whether we'd like to have this sent back
to committee and have a dis a discussion
with the community and the and the
operator potentially. Um, we could
arrange it, but it does not have to be
at our committee meeting and we make
sure that happens and we will vote on
this at the next meeting. So, do we have
a second for that? Okay, I second to
send it back. All right. So, um, if we
could have a show of hands, all those in
favor
of sending it back of sending it back
and to have a discussion, okay, with the
committee, with the operator prior to
coming back to our committee,
I just I just wanted to clarify this.
Okay. What we're holding on now is to do
what? send it back to the committee send
or
that the operator will be required to
meet with the community
and then come back to the committee. We
are sending it back to the committee
with the stipulation that the operator
will have a meeting with the with the
community prior to our meeting because
it's not going to happen in the
committee because we just we've already
done
that. Okay, we're clear on what we're
voting on. All right. Do we need a Do we
need a roll call? Is it too close? It
would be easier to do it would be better
to do the roll call. Okay, let's go for
the roll call. Okay, I will call the
names. Uh, uh, in favor,
opposed. Uh,
abstain. Tanya Aras. In favor of turning
back to committee. Okay. In favor means
you wanted to go back to committee.
Opposed mean you wanted to stay here to
vote to vote on. Kyle Thigh opposed on a
vote.
Okay. Neil Barkley.
Neil, you're muted. Yeah. Yep. Got it.
Okay. Yeah. In favor of sending it back
to committee and just say in favor. Keep
it short.
Marty Barrett opposed.
Okay. Ellie Barroso opposed.
Okay. Daniel Bernstein opposed.
Okay.
Um, Liz Burr
opposed.
Okay. Jim Collins is not here. Stu
Desesser favor.
Okay. B. Disman is not
here. Maya
Donahghue.
Okay. Robert Bartan.
He's not here. Barack Freriedman
opposed.
Okay. Jason Fromawitz opposed. Okay.
Eric Goldberg.
Okay. Justin Goldberg opposed. Okay.
Gloria Hage.
In
favor. Okay. Rabia is not here. Paige
judge opposed.
Okay.
John Keller opposed.
Okay. Uh, Rupal Kakad not here. Not
here. Kate Kennedy.
Okay. Nadim Khani is not
here. Katie Lando in favor. Okay. Sandre
Ltoff in favor.
Okay. David Levy not here. Not here.
Anton Melner opposed. Okay. Sandy McKe
in favor. Okay. Alec Militec opposed.
Okay. Rich Mintz, are you here? No, I
don't see you. Kevin O'Keefe opposed.
Okay. Uh, Rashma Patel in favor.
Okay. Steve Perez in favor. Okay. Will
Perry. Okay.
Omar Careshi is not
here. Marryiam Ralph in favor. Okay.
Michael Anroe, are you here? Not here.
Okay. Not here. Larry Sh opposed.
Okay. And Seligman, not here. Not here.
Sandra Sherrod in favor. All right. Uh,
Mubin Sadiki
in favor.
Okay. Letty Simon in favor. Okay. Mark
Thompson in favor. Okay. Gabe Tzo.
Okay. Cat Valero in favor. Okay. James
Vera in favor. Okay. Jerry Weinstein
opposed.
Okay. Sarah Whittington.
Okay. David Woods.
Okay. Shuya uh Zho.
Okay. Let me tally these up.
comparing with you.
What is this?
It's a tie.
No. Let's see.
Sounded like a tie. All right.
Nearly 20 members voted to send it back.
19 voted to keep it here.
So it goes back by the skin of our team.
But but let's be clear, it's not this
discussion is not happening at the bulk
committee. It must happen outside of
that committee. They've spent a lot of
time heard a lot of comments already. Um
I don't think we we want to do that. So
we will try we can organize a meeting.
Um
okay. Yeah we can organize a meeting. Um
yeah the current agenda of the next uh
bulk committee meeting is looking at 35
plus items. So unless you guys want to
be there for like five hours. It's
probably better to do this in a separate
session. And Justin wanted to Yeah. I
just wanted to say one thing which is um
these bald meetings you know we we spent
almost three or four hours every month
in these um this specific issue we
probably we spent a long time with it.
Um firstly those these meetings are
always open for anybody to come to. So
um people should and including board
members here should be coming to these
and you know not necessarily having such
a strong opinion 3 weeks later um if
they haven't reviewed it and I you know
Anton I just want to give respect to you
that you know these meetings run so
smoothly they're three and a half hours
four hours long and um I just want to
express appreciation for you and I think
the assumption is that this will come
back in favor because we understand that
it can worked out. It's not an, you
know, we're probably not going to change
our opinion about this particular issue,
but we understand that there should be a
dialogue.
Whether it happens before or after, I
think it's really the issue. I have this
point is because the meeting was put up
on our website. There was also a sign
very clear front door toward the hotel
with the dot and other uh signs that
this meeting graffit that particular
date and that me community were invited
to make their comments. There were only
two members of the committee that showed
up. Understood. So, let's move on to our
next
uh our next resolutions.
Oh, I'm sorry, Sarah. To that being
Sarah Wington, W committee member. I
also want to echo what my
uh members of the committee, the co-
members of the committee have said. We
spent a lot of time with this and it was
an issue that we we talked about and the
uh point I would like to make to our
community is yes we are listening but
you need to come to us and how you do
that is to go online look at what the
agendas are be in your community and
talk with other people and that would
have been
helpful of course this is 2020 hindsight
but on the other hand, we have
responsibilities to take care of and as
community members, we should know what's
going on with our community boards and
all of these committees.
All right, members, on your ballot for
this item, mark whatever you want. We'll
strip it out when we get back to the
office.
Okay, Anton, your last resolution.
[Music]
meeting and vice versa. Contact the
community board, please. Contact the
community board.
We'll reach out to the operators and try
and find a date that works for them and
then we will let you all know um what we
can arrange.
parks. That would be much appreciated.
Thank you.
Um, as we all know, we've been having
issues with the office of management
where they run their business and some
of our most contentious meetings the
bulk have do with cannabis
licenses. What the cannabis management
under the public
conveyance is to
reduce the distance between capitalist
establishments from thousand ft current
regulations to 500 ft. Yep.
Um been a lot of push back in the
community about having legal kind of
shops in our community. Never mind
having cannabis shops that are less than
5 500 ft away. So we felt as a committee
in order to limit the number of cannabis
shops in our community a th00and ft
radius rule should continue to be in
effect and not be reduced to anything
less.
The other mission that is not here, I
just want to raise it so that we're all
aware that the rules regarding distance
from houses of worship and
schools seem to be uh put in the lines
of the office can management and we will
hopefully address this at one of our
bulk meetings so that there's more
clarity in terms of distance of cannabis
dispensaries from schools.
and houses of worship and other public
conveniences.
Are there any questions?
If not, if there's no objection, we'll
now vote on the resolution. Please mark
your
ballot. Do you have a report, Anton?
Watch the website. That's
opposing.
[Music]
Have you read the resolution?
Then if you agree with it, you're in
favor. If you disagree with it, you're
opposed.
Okay. Uh, moving on to budget and
government affairs. I believe Stephen
Perez is going to be leading this one.
He's the vice
chair. Um thank you Steve. So the first
resolution is um regarding preserving
the tax exemption of municipal bonds. Um
the capital requests that you see in our
district need statement are funded
through the city's capital program which
is primarily funded through taxes and
bonds. And in the federal budget
reconciliation bill, there is discussion
that they would get rid of that and that
would increase the cost of borrowing for
these capital projects that we have by
up to 30%. It, you know, would range,
but it could be as much as that. In the
last um time they had the tax bill in
2017, they got rid of our ability as a
city to refinance our debt, which we
used to be able to do. So now we're
already doing that on a taxable basis.
And in a recent deal that New York City
did in April, um they had a billion
dollars of tax bonds which had a rate of
4.3% on 10 years and the tax book issue
which is also billion dollar a week
later had a 5.3%. So you're seeing
almost 1% increase in cost there. Um so
we wrote this resolution today. uh the
house ways and means committee actually
didn't include it in the reconciliation
bill. That's the first step, but u we'll
monitor it and we wrote this resolution.
We're presenting it and we want to send
it to our congressional.
Are there any questions?
If there's no objection, we'll vote on
the resolution and please mark your
ballots. Actually 5B
just a second. Oh, I'm sorry. 5B. Yes.
Sorry. I have I have to go.
Okay. Certainly no problem. Thank you.
All right. So, this is 5A. Come here.
5B. Oh, sorry. You're voting on 5B, but
5 A is now 5 A is next. Okay.
Okay. Please go ahead. Great. So, um 5A
is simply a proforma. uh we every year
we receive a city-wide statement of
needs from the city basically saying
about changes that are going to need
public facilities across the um the
city. So it's just we have no objection
to any of the changes that are coming.
Okay, any
questions? All right, seeing no
questions, um please vote on the
resolution and you can now submit your
ballot. Um all right, any report? Yes.
Very quickly, um it's very important.
There are two charter revision
commissions that have released interim
reports. Um we are going to study them
before our next meeting and we'll be
discussing them at our next um budget
and government affairs meeting. Um and
then the other thing that I wanted to
mention is that um we have received the
responses from the OM in regards to all
of our budget requests. So thank you
Brendan for updating the air table. All
all the updates have been made. So every
committee should go there and look at
the responses that you've received to
the
measurements and make any changes or
dialogue. We engage with those city
officials as needed.
And Stephen will will anyone from the
committee be making testimony at the
next
um at the next charter meeting? So I
wrote up testimony for you to submit.
Yes. Okay. So
because our tight deadline to submit
testimony to the charter revision
commission um based on everything that
we've already written up in resolutions
and budget requests which included
increased funding for community boards
and having the city help the community
boards find space for our public
meetings. Um we wrote I wrote a
testimony for Sandy to submit and that
will be submitted this week. Thank you.
Great. Tanya, I don't know if I was
supposed to do this or not, but I stayed
up till 2 o'clock in the morning in
Germany watching that land
use charter commission and and I didn't
submit it, you know, testimony as a as a
person to it because um it was
interesting to watch. We submitted
testimony to the mayor's charter
revision. Uh Gabes presented it. So, as
a board, we we've done that.
Um so definitely
participate as the public please. Um
youth and education we
go real quick. Yeah. Um we held a
meeting uh we passed a budget request
and committee will continue to meet uh
later this month. Thank you. Okay. Parks
and cultural affairs Neil. Hello. Uh
hello. So we had no meeting in May and
then we would just say this uh weekend
coming up will be uh it's my park day.
So throughout the district all the
different parks on Saturday you can go
and volunteer. On Sunday we'll be in the
east park of uh Stson Square Park if
you'd like to uh volunteer. All right.
Thanks everyone.
I don't I don't know the gentleman who
presented earlier about Green Street
here. Yes. is um but Neil uh I believe
you said that you could not request a
resident could request trees uh and I
remember filing um an application online
with the department of parks
to request trees on a street are you
familiar with that yeah you can go
online and request a tree and uh I would
just say the it's a process but yeah you
can go ahead and you can request
I mean you can't there's a drop there's
a drop down but then it's like grayed
out and says you can't test
yeah they actually have stopped that
process. Okay.
So that's um they're talking about an
urban forest but in our district we have
to locate trees in other places besides
on the street. So that's one of the
things that it's one of the um things
that I think the parks committee is
going to be talking about in the future.
Uh, anything else,
Neil? Okay, we'll move on to housing and
homelessness and um, sorry, Larry.
Neil, uh, on the in the East Park status
square, the fountain hasn't been running
for several years. Do you have an update
on that?
Say that. Say that one more time. East
Park, Stson Square Fountain has not been
operating for several years. Yeah,
Fountain is operating. Yeah. So, I I
know there are there's some issues with
water there and we will talk about that
in June. We're going to just talk about
the different parks in the district that
uh have water and that need water. Um
but that that's been some uh that's been
a problem for a little while. Um, you
know, we can ask we can ask uh the parks
department if they have an update on
that or at least see what the uh the
status is of where it is.
Okay. Um, housing and homelessness. Um,
we have a bit of a change in this
committee. Rich uh has decided he's
going to step down. He's been a great
chair for a long time and he's passing
on the baton. Um, so Alec Militech is
going to be our new chair and uh Sandra
Leto is our vice chair. So yes,
we're already sharing the committee. It
appates my time on board. So uh thank
you Rich. Um I'll keep it short. We have
been working on a housing study um
extending the ongoing thing for the past
couple months. Um, if you'd like an
update or to understand kind of the the
status and the progress, uh, please
attend Monday's meeting. Thanks. Yeah,
Rich was Rich was at the the pet ER
today. He said, so hopefully it went
well. Um, health and environment ovaros.
Uh, good evening everyone. So in our
meeting last week, we had the harness
expertise of licensed professional act,
which is a new bill that expands the
categories of mental health
professionals who can conduct clinical
examinations and make decisions about
involuntary mental health treatment. The
bill defines two new categories of
professionals. The qualified clinical
examiners which include psychiatric
nurse practitioners, psychologists and
clinical social workers. And the other
categories of professionals include the
previous group plus additional newly
defined professionals who can make
critical clinical decisions for
involuntary
hospitalization and perform various
functions previously restricted to
physicians.
We also had a presentation by a doctor
from NYU Longon Health on stroke
awareness, signs of stroke and what to
expect in the emergency department and
treatment of stroke. And we also started
discussion on how to bring new healthc
care facilities in our district. And one
possibility is having a micro hospital
which is a short-term acute care
hospital that focus directly on
community needs and operate with within
a compact clinical and administration
framework. basically to address
community needs in our area where
patients may have overcrowded options
for acute or emergency care at hospitals
in in our community because of the MSBI
closure. And in relation to this topic,
Brad Korn will come in our June uh
health and environmental committee
meeting to describe what health services
will be available for our community. now
that MSBI has closed. So, please come to
our meeting in June. Thank you.
And just to clarify, Brad Korn is from
um Mount Sane Beth Israel. He's been our
liaison previously.
Great.
Thank you.
Very quickly, um Neil, please submit
your ballot. I had promised Dr. Dr. Eric
Wi, who's a new CEO of Belleview, as a
representative here of the Belleview
Community Advisory Board. He wants it
known that he would like to speak as
long as possible. Sandy, I know he's
been in touch with you or his office,
but he just wanted to be known that he
would like to speak to this uh community
board about um Beth Israel uh and other
issues. So, he will be here. I've
invited him for for for May and June and
he can't make it. He feels bad. Okay.
Okay. Um board members, if you have any
old or new business to state, please
raise your
hand. Okay. Uh seeing no new business,
um Justin will now conduct a second roll
call.
Members of
members members will now call
you. Please do so now.
Okay.
Present.
Kyle
present. Martin Barrett present.
Elbyo
present.
Daniel Brooksy present. Liz
present. Jim Collins
not here. Studman
[Music]
not here. Maya,
Robert Baraban, not here. Rob Freeman
present. Jason Rollins present. Eric
Goldberg. Justin Goldberg here. Gloria
H. A not here. H Judge
here present.
Not here. Sean present. Kate
Hannity Keani
not here. Katie Lando present.
Lov here.
David Levy
here. Anton present.
Sandra Key present.
Alec Milit.
Richard Mitz not here.
O'Keefe.
Patel has left.
Cena
Perez. Will Mary
[Music]
not here. Mary
not here. Laura Sher present. Ann
not here. Sandra Sh present.
Sadiki
present. Letty Simon.
Letty, are you here? We do need your We
do need your ballot.
She's muted, but she's here. Hey, can
you hear me now? I can. Uh, would you
like to give your ballot orally? Yep.
Yep. Uh it's very easy this week. In
favor
in favor for everything. Yeah. Okay. And
and yeah, you can do that. Yeah, I can
take care of that. Okay. Thanks.
Okay. Thson present.
Gabriel,
James, present. Jerry, present. Sarah
Woodson.
David Woods here.
Okay, just give me a moment while I
record Letty's votes. It hopefully won't
take me too
long. Once that vote once that ballot is
recorded, we will tally up those votes
very quickly and we will announce the
final votes of the night.
Yeah, it's a it's a long Yeah, it's a
long one tonight.
Okay, I just submitted. Hopefully, it'll
show up. It does. All right. Thank you.
All right. Here's the final vote count
for tonight. Resolution 1A passes. 38 in
favor, none opposed. No abstensions, one
not
entitled. Resolution 1B passes. 37 in
favor, no opposed, no abstensions, two
not
entitled. Resolution
2A passes. 37 in favor, one opposed, one
abstension. No, not entitled. Resolution
2B passes. 36 in favor, two opposed, one
abstension. Resolution
3A passes, 38 in favor, zero opposed, no
abstensions. Resolution 3B was referred
back to
committee. Resolution 4 A passes. 36 in
favor, one opposed, two abstensions.
Resolution 4B, 36 in favor, two opposed,
one abstension. Resolution 4 C, 37 in
favor, one opposed, one
abstension. Resolution 4 D, 36 in favor,
two opposed, one abstension. It passes.
Resolution
4E, 37 in favor, one opposed, one
abstension. It passes. Resolution 4F, 37
in favor, one opposed, one abstension.
It passes.
Resolution
4G, it passes. 36 in favor, one opposed,
two abstensions. Resolution 4H, it
passes. 36 in favor, one opposed, two
abstensions. Resolution 4 I, it passes.
36 in favor, one opposed, two
abstensions. Resolution 4J, it passes.
abstensions.
4K passes. 4 L passes overwhelmingly. 4
M passes overwhelmingly. 4 N passes
overwhelmingly. 4 O passes
overwhelmingly. 4 P same thing. 4 Q same
thing.
Four 4 R, same thing.
4S, same thing. 4T, same thing. 4 U was
referred back to committee. 4 V
overwhelmingly passes. 5 A, 39 in favor,
unanimous. 5B 39 in favor. Unanimous.
And that is it. Yay. Back to Sandy.
There are no objections. We will adjourn
the meeting at
9:51. Thank you all. Oh, wow.
Good meeting.